français bah ouais match retour entre
max et ou pas l'offre avec les pièces
blanches pour max écoute mon espère une
victoire une qualif
est ce que tu penses si on se qualifie
on fait comme les supporters lyonnais en
mode web abusé tabac le gagner la
première ronde
c'est les mêmes vénère quand même quoi
non mais non mou des banderoles des
chèvres et où s'alignent les qualifiés
il est le maïs mais j'ai halluciné alors
c'était un truc de ouf ça du coup on
sera très heureux si on se qualifie et
away tu agis mais non tu agis même pas
s'ils se qualifient dit on se qualifie
en fait on est tous qualifiés les mecs
on est français de toute façon on est en
finale on est en finale c'est la
catastrophe alors attendez-vous vers les
chattes pas où on va on va tous bien
ferme à vérifier que tout marche
relation au sujet d'appels mon côté
c'est la vérificateur j'aime bien ce
terme vérifie cas là on peut tout faire
en un an
oui voilà ça marche bombe attends je
vérifie youtube je vérifie tout et tout
et online la mv la date n'est toujours
aussi con c'est beau après tant d'années
tigha sachez qu'il est déjà écrit salut
les tontons monsieur stosic qu'il te dit
ce fils d'alger c'est trop calme tandis
que c'est trop calme
tout petit déjà il te suffit de mettre
des gens père est à peine démarré le mas
le live via une minute genre tranquille
c'est de la merde en fait prof et ans et
anton live basta taxe carbone dégage on
ne veut plus voir ta gueule sur ce site
déjà quasiment non ouvrables c'est trop
calme
le shot fenêtres et bonne couche à tu
veux fenêtre est d'abord un pur chemin
un copain mais je les plus chers les
chats aiment bien être assis aux
fenêtres exactement non mais ça joue
aulas alors paramètres du chat ma
fenêtre et je le vois à temps
quitter le mode paramètres modérateur ou
of web on s'acquitte le modérateur et
après
1 pourquoi ne peut pas être modérateur
en fin mai à wigan on battait quand même
modérateur après une fois que l'eau vers
mais tu peux pas le fenêtre et en tant
que modérateur
mais bordel j'ai le droit quoi c'est
subtil gauvin est bon mais enfin en fait
c'était pas comme ça avant et à la
première fois que c'est arrivé j'étais
en sueur je vous ai pu ouvrir le chat
existe pas c'que t'es pas modérateur
dégage t modérateur dégâts je suivrai
repas le chat c'est important mais je
sais je suis à fond dans le signe que
fils de scie mais j'avais compris le
truc mais la duck software fois que je
l'avais en tant que modérateur
avec ma petite épée c'était plus
compliqué pendant que l'on regarde quand
même le très grand match fable nihal
sarine à prague avant d'arbitrer ce
temps joue contre minutes auxquelles est
prêt pour ça comme ça mais comme ce but
et je la même langue que mike les blancs
voie royale sarine très fort mois les
masques et me [ __ ] combes et 8b quatre
ballades choix de prendre des 59 très
mauvais près de vous bah je pense tu
fais pas tu fous ces sept baies 5 ici
enfin peut calculer où je suis peut-être
fait p5 direct non toi tu t'en fous mais
fou g3 je n'aurais pas fait je deviens
sont basses et des victoires en 2 h que
moi je vois que tu te fais pousser cette
gamme tête mais j'ai bâti le petit ça
doit ni dans cette variante en quinze
coups bonjour mais une question fausse
haute qui avait machin de 5 pour celui
resté le plan le tout premier choix en
là il prend et je fais à 7
mais bon après je peux mais non mais le
petit ça donne il a fait un truc
fantastique il a eu cette position
contre lui à bombay 9 et b5
ou peut-être tu as fait qu'aider cette
vache lui comment il a fait mais il a eu
cette structure bombard palmarès chez
les cadres et les f3 jeter bouffe et ont
pu enfin attendons les retours bio c'est
bon tu as quand même fait nul contre
cariat qui donc fait très doué mais ça
pique un peu les yeux quoi mais là c'est
manche de magadan nice rennes c'est
quand même assez ridicule joue pas les
divas
ce coût ne m'appartient pas cette
position est nul mais il ya un gars qui
amène commentaires youtube très marrant
aujourd'hui la hâte de voir les
commentaires du match pour le
championnat du monde mvl karl scène avec
vlad qui veut dire que vous te dire en
un mec sur youtube nativement entendre
en finale championnat du monde va
d'achat coup il est complètement nul
il ne connaît pas incroyable surtout
n'appartient pas à cette position saft
il joue aux échecs raf se mater
extraordinaire comme quand tu arrives là
dessus les joueurs quand tout le temps
parce que si vous avec montella d'un top
fiche contre 1 2 0 n'ont pas renoncé
tandil aucune culture ne connais pas il
ne connaît pas la partie b de trigorine
1885 gérard comont comment ne pas
connaître enfin comment ne pas savoir
c'est bon il l'amène pas su qu'ils
imaginent quoi passer comme il me
parlait partie de galfingue contre
gritche ou quoi galfond n'était pas au
courant je prendrais tu as tu été
vice-champion du monde tu n'es pas au
courant commence comment est ce possible
est ce qu'être champion du monde et
finalement durera ce je ne sais pas quoi
non c'est quand même beau d'être
champion du monde en connaissant rien à
ce point bas c'est beau quoi non mais
bravo quoi tu dois être vraiment très
doué vu tes connaissances très limitées
quoi c'était génial que peut-être vlad
en fait tu vas dans ses chiottes la
boutonne via bouquin de galfingue
positionne alpes l'est quoi vraiment un
livre très triste intéressant quoi le
mec n'a rien écrit quoi oui peut-être
il s'en sort comme papier toilette
contre mais s'est adjugé à vlad comment
battre papa aux échecs aux olives de
galles fans je ne vois pas la différence
c'est à peu près comme d'ailleurs
beaucoup mieux comment battre papa aux
échecs ou moins j'ai appris des trucs
quand même quoi
ce serait beau de guyot qui émeuvent
elle gagne aujourd'hui sur le point de
bonus bas tout à fait alors attendez à
des gens qui cite montesquieu des
pronostics des machins ya l'ombre de
kiev il ya des gens il ya des gens dans
le chat on va pas on va me tout
reprendre c'est un internaute propres
délires quoi c'est fantastique
enfin d'insultés c'est là qu'il faut que
de la merde a joué 24 c'est
extraordinaire quand même du coup on n'a
encore pas la partie aujourd'hui
ouais je crois je suis sur mon téléphone
et 6 ou quoi on est de bonne humeur
oui tu fous c'est quand même un peu plus
important de français mme lagarde les
parties à chaque fois mais tu sais que
même quand il regarde sur follow che
c'est tout tu peux le voir il est mort
de rire devant son téléphone juste parce
que il fâché par la cage ont un coût et
il est là en train de faire un fou rire
quoi puisque comment at il joué ça ou je
pense la partie de goulinat contre causé
nues quand elle a fait fou des deux il a
fait un fou rire total tout ça tiens ça
commençait enfin voir la réponse est
parti on va le faire à la main le truc
oui mais voilà je lance à la main
fabre est exactement va du coup avec
topalov donc là on a été des cadres et
les mecs désolé mais c'est le temps de
voilà on recadre donc on a bien mv
l.blanc topalov noir on va mettre les
coups on va récupérer deux chaises bombe
tu me bats c'est une mine bas-rhinoise
une berlinoise la finale ouais bon
accueil points 4 j'ouvre le truc dont je
vois la boîte c'est finalement les mecs
à une petite seconde et des six bout des
cinq dames seront de retour enfin bon il
ya pas encore de quoi prendre ça ne
saurait tarder puisque génial
les galbes ouais voilà on en est là et
on va voir donc la réputation de la
berlinoise
aujourd'hui les amis les amis d'une
image 3 cette embauche chaque fois la
ranger 4 s'inquiète pas ça va bien se
passer
bon du coup topito pas assez de fer
phosphate j'imagine ou à 65 tonnes
est ce qu'on peut dire topito pas en
sueur face à l'élite web est issu déjà
jeu qui grille aujourd'hui pas mais
c'est intéressant en fait je sais que si
l'on intègre la berlinoise on avait
parlé l'autre jour et de la bomba en
moins on va voir un peu quelle est leur
leurs projets par an tu ne peux plus la
jouer balle à 17 il me plairait non mais
oui mon top ne travaille plus donc il
sait pas mais ce serait déjà beau les
commentaires quoi oui topalov tu es
complètement nu le cheer entrer dans la
berlinoise dégage c'est extraordinaire
on ferait des gens insulter quoi qui ne
s'est pas jouée non mais faut hausser le
coût du half the way i am akon et il
sait d'avancé ce que j'ai tout cas et
jouer les contres maxime tusa à riga il
aida les crèmes bio souffert même il
paraît que maintenant tu souffres en
fait depuis alpha 0 donc ça c'est une
info vlad exclusivement les mecs qui m'a
lâché au dîner donc la raison pour ça
qu'on rigole avec fable à raison pour
laquelle les haut niveau il ne joue plus
la berlinoise ca/cause d'alpha 0 qui
fait que c'est très difficile à défendre
maintenant donc cramique avait tort
quelque part enfin alors c'est une belle
gagne là bas rhinoise affûté sinon les
bernois se tient attention a donc là
c'est une partie vraiment décisive pour
cramique quelque part as tu eu raison à
dans la loire en fait tu joues ta
carrière là-dessus rocton de mam est en
difficulté dans l'ouverture attention
fabia d un vin qui sont lâchés
ben moi en fait je vais ramener pour
riches attendait les amis on va mettre
la partie sur le petit échiquier de
chaises monde
mam est en difficulté dans l'ouverture
ben non c'est balance c'est juste
théorique dont bah oui enfin je sais pas
où il a discuté l'instant issue coupe
non mais mam et ben je sais pas c'est
quoi le problème
là c'est juste la position très connu
mais on n'avait pas dit que c'était un
peu mieux pour les blancs cette variante
là on n'est pas regarder ensemble pour
les parrains théoriquement mais après
apple
le truc où les jours ce copil wayne des
arbitres ou elle tout ça ouais donc
c'était donc ça le coteau poste des gens
sûrs après je trouve 10 ou dans le gers
un bain mais il a dû préparer parce
qu'il fait at-il alpha 0 d'ailleurs fall
tati pour avoir plus rien il mais je
pense qu'il prépare fait avec son faux
il joue juste
avec son savoir mais après je paye ici
la nuque ou plutôt c'est plus tranchant
c'est plus dans son style en a peut-être
qui sait que devant le calcul sait plus
trop ouf c'était son style c'est dur
quand même quand tu avais un style un
peu comme ça viril dont j'ai envie de
dire quand tu y ségur aprilia des gens
de section des piqûres de testostérone
et tout pour rester jeune non mais
vraiment en fait vraiment vraiment aux
états unis je crois surtout c'est
populaire a peut-être des gens dans le
chat qui vont qui vont aiguiller là
dessus mais peut-être c'est ça qui
devrait faire dans ce domaine
il parait il paraît que il paraît que ça
te booste vraiment en fait
et en plus à un peu agressif ça donne
envie de te taper un peu les gens ou
quoi pavel qui se serait du dopage non
bah écoutes je sais pas d'ailleurs c'est
une bonne question
youtube qui dit qu'ils font ça dans le
cyclisme à partir de 15 noms de quelques
mois je connais des gélules de testo il
ya du doping dans le chase the game ah
bon on en parlait ce genre de trucs
[Rires]
j'en parle plutôt tu peux te mets à yuna
kim était testicules s'atrophie car
elles n'ont plus besoin d'en produire
naturellement away ca
c'est dommage ça mon sac de l'hudson
cash flow qui nous ont si j'ai des
jeunes victoire sur la bergère dans le
top 10 si moi je te lis fabiano djebbour
est question en fait je penserai tous
les matins au petit déj n'en font jamais
battue continue de me disent tous
copains qui étaient dans le top 10 où
l'on mange de jouer je n'ai jamais tu
max quand il était petit mais bon enfin
même pas un petit qui était très petit
et la phase de 30 2004 quatre ou cinq
chez plupart des mois les faits dès 15
ans l'olympien qui ça rend pas agressif
c'est des doses légère pour équilibrer
le niveau de testo d'un mec de 30 ans
mais c'est bien ou pas du coup à faire
ce que j'ai déjà entendu du bien entendu
du cheval fou des sceptres faute non
mais du coup sur coup je ne connais pas
battu mais pas à moi je suis pas un fana
de marines aux cantonales congés les
blancs bon bah j'ai vite quoi enfin je
joue détroit où tu vois franchement pas
mal finale et puis le gauche dès lors
qu'elles sont joue pas ça sa moto tu
peux jeter un coup d'oeil à ce que fait
n'est peau contre galles fans je pense
que gaël fonde va la tenter avec les
blancs clairement voilà monsieur
l'onglet rien de rien de fou pour le
moment bref chouchou pour le moment
écoute je fais un tour des stades juste
comme ça
bon il ya comme ami c
c'est intéressant mais bon ok je pense
c'est du solide
wang hao navarra ces nantis bas-rhinoise
voilà avec des trois quarts yakine à
bondoukou aux navarrais topalov les deux
jeux là bas rhinois sa carrière qu'il
avait une petite variante de l'italienne
nous qui aimons ce n'est un gris dont
une anglaise auquel fendre là ça joue ça
va être un peu
il sauve j'essaye un truc contre la
petrov de youla andric in vosges taceq
c'est une drague au sinn fein neto est
content il faut 17 tendent à l'arago
zinal femmes aux ragots ligne de corner
n'est donc au vert quand tu joues avec
food et ça ça veut dire tu veux l'être
cacher en serbie tech3 généralement
attends je vais juste remettre les noms
tu vois je vais faire les choses bien
puisque aujourd'hui ça s'est mieux
ouvert c'est bizarre qu'on n'est pas le
truc direct aux développeurs qui
écoutent oui mais en fait je sais que
monsieur qu'est ce qu'un changement est
les seuls à commenter ça il est à fond
sur le grand tchèque seront là du coup
tournoi en jeu il n'ya que nous et ses
six enfants d'ici terre dans mes cheveux
sont des vraiment fou soit personne ne
va toucher n'importe quoi je ne sais pas
je pense je pense que tout le monde fait
n'importe quoi en fait paraître j'espère
et je souhaite quand même enfin j'veux
dire si un tournoi qui compte chez lui
comme un qui viennent londres qui n'est
pas londres en fait on fait mais on est
les seuls gens sur internet a vraiment
faim je sais pas sur tweets chez ce que
il ya d'autres gens je vais regarder en
fait j'en sais rien est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres d'autres personnes qui stream
ce tournoi je pense m'en vais te
confronter les seuls à s'intéresser à ce
truc là en fait sa requête tout le monde
s'en fout mais qui deviennent bons coups
mc sme a par contre la photo de chasse
qui montrent ces photos déjà hier en
fait j'ai compris le concept du stream
après a posteriori de quoi en fait elle
montré les photos qu'elle prenait à
l'écran comme ça à l'écran mais c'est
que des photos de ma sphère du coup
au programme du monde a été super
heureuse des heureux cependant en tête
30 minutes alizés merci de chasse comme
fr merci
il renvoie non tel raz effet rangé
renvoi quoi bon ballon là que ça a joué
on va le clou du team en fait il a chopé
le cool thing
non mais ya eu autour d un look et sa
cellule team rouaroua civic et la valeur
topalov éliminer les un taux plafond
tueur on m'oblige gros client de cette
tristement déjà s'y fait complètement
raide à vritz tu n'y connais rien que
nikkei g5 attaqué ajoute m me
connaissent par coeur je pense
il a très bien analysé mais en fait oui
il est bon sur le management
il a appelé les pompiers les mecs c'est
c'est fini c'est fini
belle victoire de m vl après ce g 4 8
jeux attend un objet cataphiles à
cavaillon cette web à beijing
il faut vite voilà et qui n'a pas encore
joué maxime mais ça ne ne devrait tarder
petit vlv ans et f4 en fait ce serait
bien dans l'idée tu fais fi 4 pour faire
f5 et concernant cette majorité
[Musique]
globalement en fait comment dire si vous
fait un petit résumé sur la berlinoise
pourquoi c'est si triste pour les ducks
normalement tu fais un blocage sur
quatre manches
donc les blancs galère à fond pour
annoncer leur majorité depuis on a le
droit
bon bah c'est ils ont par trop galérer
quoi donc c'est ça le bon côté après ça
serait assez solides pour les noirs
victimes en rien n'est fait mais où que
se confiant et f4 jouer mais moi ce
qu'ils vont en confiance et qui connaît
qu il sait ce qu'il fait il fait face et
toi t'es nul moi je m'appelle alpha 0
quoi dix minutes on arrive déjà cette
position en jouant vite
non mais j'attends et je lâche des
enfants femmes
si je peux remonter la partie mais c'est
une berlinoise les mecs se débite dit
coup de théorie va mais on s'en fait
ça ils vont pas réfléchir beaucoup pour
rentrer ma position salut c'est déjà la
barre on est donc là pour le moment
c'est passé juste assez tu joues tout
tempo et puis la faire enfin c'est juste
des prépas quoi sont des grands maîtres
de mémoire mais là du couteau woerth n'a
plus de démarches pense un bref 4 en
avant bourse débrouiller tout seul
peut-être même avant non non mais avant
comme bonifié food et satisfait ce qu'il
fait et droits civiques c'est le blanc
on bat tête g4 il sait pas mais a pas le
choix et il faut huit dossiers quoi mais
la main ce premier coup il peut être si
c'est pas exactement va déconner normes
epa tempo mais mais c'est peut-être pas
facile à jouer en fait pleinement vos
cils et blanc de fonds de fonds f5 après
est ok c'est trois fois 6 4 tu veux
faire a insisté piastres lorient nantes
a pas d'espacé quand même faut croquer
j'aurais pensé c'est la première ligne
de cette petite ordi donc ça peut être
soit le meilleur coup mais h5 ses
premiers trucages de réponse est oui si
j'imagine pour activer la toile mais
après ils vont te conseille pas assisté
aux cinq puisque kg 5 kg tolérer ou pas
tu as des subtilités tu peux commencer à
dire oui bon je m'en fous de ce qu'il
fait je fais à cinq je pose de l'autre
côté non mais tu as 5 à 4 francs de
l'espace
ça arrive ce plan tu peux bleus d'être
pensé à b6 bon tu caches tout au moins
je sais pas ces cinq c'est peut être une
option si je le ferais pas mais ces cinq
femmes six pouces et 6 ou à m caliance
et si ces univers des 4b calepin taplin
de planque
et tout se ressemble en fait c'est très
bien qu'elle ait acheté enfin pour moi
ça aurait vraiment été logique ce que tu
as aussi le plan tourache si ce qui peut
arriver
ouais 500 projets de j j ajoute que ce
jour voilà mais nous a menti et
détourage qui a purgé trois tu t'en fous
et peut-être maintenant moi j'aurais
fait ces cinq pour faire pour la et ses
trois aujourd'hui
fauvez chaque nouveau jeu 3g 3g l'agf
cet enlèvement qu'ont donc ça a l'air
pur farc 66 hockey et du couffo calculé
cavaliers 6 puisque d'un asmat en 1ère
ou non on va devoir le nord c'est que
t'es pas coordonnées tapati tour si les
dents arrive en fait développé ça va
mais même là peut-être savoir je ne sais
pas mais si tu as c'est juste pas simple
il faut bien calculer et au pire des cas
tu pour une finale je sais pas me
compliquer mais du coup c'est pas simple
de prendre la bonne décision écrit noir
si t'as jamais sans doute renversa on va
te connais bien claude stock ya des
pièges de partout d'ailleurs c'est
possible donc voilà c'est génial quoi
dans le chat en anglais dit keith chef
say that the rational réfuté it est
valide à 0 quoi c'est extraordinaire
d'être dans le chat de la partie les
mecs en anglais tous les mecs décrivent
en date quatre chefs faudrait que vous
citiez quatre chefs saïda disguise nul
quoi nul nul
mettez des nuls le partout avec des
hauts et des bas il a fait 6 à tout va
ce serait beau aussi de chez pac wav
l'adq hfc saïdi skype eus ar de navarre
à face à ce crime
en fait si ça je pense
je préfère enfin tu dégages le g4 g5
cinq plus tard cette envie mais tu
penses tu connais où il connaît pas qui
dit tout à l'heure ouais non mais
connaît un peu mais économe en bien que
matt ludo qui écrit hills ou décédés
bilingue
c'est triste il note nat l'être mais en
fait réside à ce manque
il connaissait même en islande ouais
bien sûr il vraiment connu en fait non
pas oublier de penser que c'est à dire
france a surtout non je crois que c'est
un vraiment enfin vraiment beaucoup de
gens qui le connaissent
vlad chef c'est du la times cole paul
murphy
[Rires]
aïe aïe aïe ça pourrait vraiment devenir
un même quoi il est trop perçu son
compte steam punk lines un bien fou et
surtout le dauphin quoi toute ma vie je
vis à quoi cramique maladie et glossy
cité m llodra mais ce serait bon en fait
d'aller sur tous les achats des partis
en drogue les deux éditeurs autour is
going to be found to be found entouré de
cette fresque en fait c'est traduire un
tout neuf citations légendaire et les
mettre sur le chat en anglais pourrir le
truc quoi ça c'est tout ce dont faure
nous entoure
[Rires]
[Musique]
d'où la nantes dauphin alors nous pose
comme question comment les noirs ont
développé leur tour à 8 bat ils vont
faire b 6-3 bessette est développé à
tour quoi plus tard quoi tranquille 5 à
4 pour des ménages en riz n'ont pas
globalement tu veux ressortir des pièces
petit à petit donc dans l'idéal tu fais
b6 3b cette c5 le foot la transe et 6 tu
fais h5 consacrer des menaces soient h1
la tour le fou qui jouent ensemble ton
cavalli va revenir en jeu je prends des
cinq ans j'ai six quelque part sur tes
pièces les pilotes la perte de foot tu
fais six tours tout et tu défonce les
blancs quand même mais bon ça c'est dans
un rêve
bref oui tu peux aussi j'allais être
tour à 5 tours des 5 et développer le
tour iasi ceci n'arrive aussi ce truc
bizarre mais bon le truc c'est la
colonne des quand tu ne contrôles pas du
tout eu peur des problèmes mais non mais
c'est compliqué en fait cette finale à
halle berry ne s'est jamais simple sa
riche pour les deux couleurs en fait que
je parle bien car c'est en fait c'est ça
passe pour un truc ultra solide hyper
chiant mais tu veux tu es contre chance
h et 15 min mal à croire que cette
variante cette position noir et
théorique est correct
c'est comme cela mais la mairie n'a cédé
prix d'1 sa toujours mais le tour une
308 machin je suis sur sa petite
délinquance
en tout cas c'est figé quatre coups
principal ok ça nous laisse pas le choix
kg 5 coquet 34 parties choisies 8
les catcheurs c'est normal web de 30 une
partie voilà et h6 neuf parties donc il
ya plein de partie dans les bons joueurs
sont apparemment l'élite total mais tu
as quand même mcshane ya juste avec les
north qu'abattu adams nayer ya joué avec
les nerfs lui il a perdu contre yves
rouge qu du baril du baril dit lassé
d'être un azéri je pense 26 et quelques
deviendrait robson
voilà mon président je connais pas trop
mais peut-être des joueurs
correspondants sont baptisés musulmans à
mexico pékinois ça c'est email un autre
par email
si les mecs par email ont joué en a deux
qui ont peu par email voilà non mais
c'est pas si pauvre ça va pas ajouté
maxime joue assez vite il doit siffler
mais la berlinoise c'est quand même
hyper théorique mais c'est l'ouverture
peut-être la plus analysé depuis 20 ans
ouais et salut à tous crins 333 mathieu
qui veut nous rejoindre
voilà matures et où on voit j'ai déjà
analysé cette variante jusqu'au 35e
c'est beau non mathieu il connaît
forcément bon jeu pour me demander sa
décrue des stocks
j'ai ça dans mes fichiers gelé déjà
analysé quoi as tu avais déjà bizarre de
réfléchir à utiliser itunes u surface
vers ce qu'on disait quand même alors on
lâche des infos qu'on va lever je ne
sais pas jouer il a réfléchi réussissent
très très grave
comment as tu pu réfléchir à ce nom mais
ça veut la logique d'investissement ce
que je disais tu dégages ce qu'elle
valait je suis invalide m'a dit qu'il se
sentait que mathieu cornette c'était ça
relève quelque part quoi je pense qu'il
faut absolument que vlad yann chez
mathieu vivre trois mois
jean ici tu vois et ce rêve ou en fait
mathieu ça devienne une vraie relève de
vlad quoi ce serait pour quoi bon ça a
pas l'air de te si si et oui f5 une
partie de nouvelles contre klein mais
c'était le coach explique donc donc
lâché 5 jouable sur open d'ailleurs
kremnica fmh si ça reste pour l'instant
ouais bon ok le 4-3-3 soins va pas faire
autre chose majorité ne le crois pas je
te dis au catch pas pourquoi mais la
cata par f5
bah en fait sur qualif 3 soit disant f5
c'est peut-être le coup c'est ce que
matschiner jeu
[Musique]
ok sur carhaix le 4 pour le moment elle
tu prends ici
oui et du coup bon ok je passe ici lors
de ce contre 5 mais bon c'est la partie
adam ce match à lorient tout à l'heure
et du coup qui avait lieu 4 sinon pour
moi n'y est pas 2,5 après tu fait rage 5
verset 5 bien sûr genre b6 parata plein
de coups quoi mi5 à tout cas il prend
ses 5 langues et je vais faire à chaque
jeudi un peu tôt oui mais bon enfin pied
pour que finalement ça sera jamais non
mais h5 pourquoi pas non elle 500 hommes
et je ferais bien v6 va un petit truc
développement avons trop la merde ce que
l'impact des caraïbes 4 c'est qu'il est
un peu mais bon d'un autre côté qu'elle
enlève 3 tu vas y ait un peu mais ouais
mais tu vas jouer qui est bien c'est
trois jours je compte besson il va être
votre nouveau connecté même il n'a pas
de casse de d'atterrissage pour web mais
ouais y aller tous les papes tête à un
moment tu vas chez patrick cinq poissons
son plan d'affaires qui est bien c'est 3
rbds 5 passes tu peu après faut éviter à
tout petit tour va juste tu contrôles
bien quoi maintenant tu m'as convaincu
max réfléchit toujours max max réfléchi
ou alors je reçois pas du coup quand
j'ai juste regardé aussi la partie n'est
pas juste vite fait je la mets sur le
petit écran
parce que l'ordinateur de nos coûts
rouge pour les peaux mais bon je sais
pas à quel point je peux regarder
quj pourquoi quj mais je pense à la
théorique encore non il est transféré à
l'ouverture ouais c'est est anglaise
qu'il est fou 17 courts où je sais pas
si justin cours et à moins qu'ils aient
une invitation directe je sais pas de
quoi vous vu de loin comme ça je vois
pas le drame encore pleinement il ya
aussi eu 5 c'est vraiment fort je sais
pas parce que le foot et ça te prend la
casse pour le cavalier ou ce soit la
raison comme ça c'est possible
ok les rues kalou 4e maxime donc comme
tu l'avais prévu j'avais une chance sur
deux mais bon
fallait-il encore la voir ouais donc du
coup maintenant topalov je sais pas il
peut jouer un peu tout les quotas sont
on a dit des bêtises ça me semble plus
un truc un peu stable h5 s'il veut un
tabou why not
quand ils calquent ou parlant je lisais
le chat non je dirais b6 mais bon h5
évidemment c'est une option ouais mais
coûtant à voir intéressant comme partir
non non c'est toujours intéressant ses
positions c'est juste pas spectaculaire
parce que ta pâte d'amande d'attaquer
mais stratégiquement toujours important
et intéressant et ouais on verra mais où
je sais que maxime il est sérieux sur
son ouverture il ya bien là bien bosser
parce que tiennent c'est un bon
spécialiste et du coup il n'est jamais
insipide à clément là dessus avait
surtout vu tu gagnes pas tout le temps
évidemment c'est celui pour l'armée mais
il crée toujours un peu de jeu et des
difficultés son adversaire on eût dit
dans le chat que galp on va jouer pour
gagner avec les blancs on en parlait
hier femmes
bah oui je pense à la rame en existe on
fiche du tournoi 1000 ça si jamais il
veut jouer le tournoi bat autant qu'ils
pourraient bien voir en plus tu n'es
plus rapide et 8 s'il est il quand même
pas mal
donc tu vas prendre ta chance donc à des
blancs en lente mais je pense que
california c'est pas un super
appariement tu vas dans le sens où à
ils jouent à domicile et c'est un peu le
seul tournoi qui joue gros tournoi de
l'année qui joue et je pense qu'il a
plus à coeur de faire un bon résultat
que d'autres joueurs qui jouent pour
rien quoi
ouais non mais là aussi je pourrais mais
c'est ça tu as raison ils jouent à
domicile et depuis tata lui faire
plaisir
non mais bien sûr c'est parce qu'elles
font là mais je crois que celui qui a le
plus sa beauté son tournage c'était n'a
qu'à la dernière fois non mais ça s'en
fait et je vais contre topalov premier
rang au québec par et puis après il
finit le rapide avec les noirs mais en
plus tu vas tu as perdu un frère avec
les blancs et les noirs à la deuxième
si jamais tu vas revenir dans le match
mais que tu joues des quatre où je sais
pas je fais un truc sans trop de
théorique 6b si souvenez cet adn ou non
candidat m'accepter truc tout symétrique
vas tu sais qu'ils sont fous quand il
veut pas gagner
il préfère stream r oui mais je veux
dire ok mais à part lui qui a vraiment
sa beauté les autres bons ils n'ont pas
perdu exprès non plus
j'ai même radjabov qui disait qu'il s'en
fichait de jouer et ses interviews qui
n'était pas motivé et c'est bon ça
allait jusqu'à l'armageddon
et ils étaient gagnants dans le merapi
ou 1er bis contre du boeuf une
opposition il avait de plus en plus fin
il a été gagné juste bon bah y est
arrivé mais mais mais mais juste n'a
qu'à en termes de coûts jouer de choix
d'ouverture et tout ça à lui c'est le
pire que j'aie façon j'en avais un peu
parlé dans la vidéo que j'avais fait
j'avais un peu la prépa qu'on avait fait
avec maca ouais voilà la prépa elle
était torse en 10 minutes en des prunes
sont ni les plus d'automne web après pas
la négrette est hors champ du budget it
a vu le résultat
c'est injuste il ya urgence un crochet 2
h tandis que tu penses tu prends g4 avec
les noirs de toute façon tu gardes
attention or l attention à prendre ça ne
sent pas mauvais temps tu vas prendre
tôt ou tard mais
en fait j'aime bien quand tu as le choix
de prendre de le réserver de manière
générale au cas où tu voudrais pas à
prendre
ouais tu donnes juste l'option des
troubles en de faire un tour h à un jour
alors pour l'instant c'est ridicule de
rachat et est clean enfin en fait c'est
pas aussi les blancs ont menacé de faire
j'y prends 5 ou g5 c'est juste ils
veulent surtout pas faire ça aux
patrouilles et toutes les cases blanches
donc en gros faire a changé c'est un
coup que tu fera vraisemblablement un
jour où peut-être pas d'ailleurs mais
autant le faire on ça t'arrange donc je
veux dire philosophiquement parlant je
le ferai pas puisque tu ferais un coup
comme fou 17 éventuellement tu calcules
art il faut 17 kg 5 ou pas bah tout sous
l'un peut que le club de rodez danger
stocks d'améliorer partir en 8ème alors
est ce que tu as le temps théoriquement
de faire ça quel problème c'est qu'ils
touchent là et là ouais ouais j'ai pas
vu non mais h projet je vais faire juste
fou 17 après 3 g iii mais bon c'est à
dire simple kf5 aussi en coin non ça
pour maxime c'est tranquille oui mais
cette chance un jour mais pas maintenant
non je suis soit b6 ou potentiels pour
tous caché avec le roi et habitat tour
et peut-être faire ensuite ces cinq
aussi ou avant c5 c6 ça peut être une
idée m est sûre avec laurence heavy to
you tu veux mais voilà première
ouverture deuxième c'est peut-être de
jeu kg 6 pourquoi pas ce que tu lis
berton fois de suite et évite un peu f5
patata que 5
même si parfois les blancs peuvent se
permettre d'ouvrir le jeu justement
comme une arme pour l'ordre au quai
était mieux développe énormément mais en
gros ce parreira sur un ces deux coups
d'éclat je pense est une très bonne
position pour maxime même si en termes
de gestion de match
ce comment il n'a pas peur de se faire
éliminer ou quoi t'as juste à petit
position wells tranquille quoi
maintenant complètement complètement non
mais c'est bien enfin toute façon ce que
je pensais bonnes stratégies de match
approche et ben c'est de ne pas prendre
trop de risques tu joues pour gagner
s'envoyer en l'air et 6 nuls parce que
toute façon tu es favori est largement
favori d'un
pin topalov a toujours eu la réputation
de très bons et rapides même à son
apogée donc en fait maintenant son
vampire ça doit être bon mais quand même
battu d'un cas qui ne l'a pas battu les
départage sont juste après ou demain en
provenance d'inde main bien sûr il
faudrait réussir à faire les départage
la semaine d'après quoi une semaine de
repos pour bien se reposer avant les
départs touche que non mais je sais pas
trop que le format peut on peu
différemment tu fais peut-être les
départage direct après pourquoi pas du
rad pas vrai je vais remplir bien c'est
très long les départage
c'est à deux parties en 25 minutes ray
schultz 10 secondes par coup
s'il ya un partout ce qui arrive à deux
parties en 15 puis après tu as dit blitz
qui est potes ça l'armageddon mais au
bout du bout quoi donc en fait si tu
essaies après la partie ce soir jusque
là mais convient à 90 m et rejoint oui
mais bon c'est le concept du tie-break
qua non à médoc et juste à soit tu fais
direct un départage blitz et 6 nuls
armageddon basse à moi je veux un c'est
beaucoup et c'est comme si le tennis
suffisait 6 6 ont l'envié on va jouer un
tie-break en 45 points c'est une pierre
mondy partager ses plus hauts je vois
c'est que randy relevé redémarrage qui
est plus long que je vais faire ça dure
une planque
ici en plus c'est d'autant plus long que
souvent tapas camacho départage à tête
de trois matchs quoi je sais pas combien
on peut avoir de 4,1 là ils font tous
nuls en 8 mai du coup tu obligé
d'attendre que le dernier finit pour une
relance et la deuxième ronde
tu vas pas redire relancer des partis
faire du bordel pour le dos rond dans sa
note donc en fait c'est le plus long
possible quoi c'est beau
pourquoi mam et ils donnent ils donnent
plus 1,60 l'ordi mais on a la position
sous le maximum le petit truc grille
ouais
ce serait quand même la super nouvelle
si mam et se fait éliminer que des
pauses fait éliminer j'ai envie de te
dire maxime gagné puis et puis voilà
quoi prépare-toi qua non mais devant
l'ordi soit il et fou soit ces juges
bien je sais pas si la ddjs bombe mais à
angola pression peut être mauvaise pour
les noirs peut-être parce que t'as pas
d'espacé déjà il aime bien alors
d'ivoire l'espace mais qu' il imagine on
va faire du tour g1 torje saint grat et
h5 tu as une belle occasion de 5
pourrait-on cavaillé un jour c'est cinq
potes fragile fin aux expulsions que je
trouve plutôt sympa avec les blancs
bizarre cette prépa quand même de ma
mère mais en fait ça au 16e coup d'amd 6
il me semble que maintenant ces dames à
le coup moderne que je pense si je me
souviens c'est ce que la garde mme avait
joué à gibraltar et dame b 6 voici donc
un petit avantage blanc c'est ça c'est
un fait ça c'est pas vraiment la manière
moderne de jouer en fait les blancs t
ils font plutôt aux prises en passant et
26 maintenant très tôt 11e coupant là je
crois un ils font qu'une prise en
passant qu'il prend cahier des six vous
prendra me prend marché en fin ça c'est
comme ça qu'ils jouent maintenant mais
qu'elle rêve de mach instinct
dans les années 90 2000 et avait pas le
parti d'adams girafe et ça me plaisait
mais il a joué super vite en bas soit il
enveloppe soit il a vraiment analyser
parce qu'il ya un ordi plus puissant que
tu doutes chez secondes donc fait c'est
ce qui fait soit il craque on espère
qu'ils craquent
c'est bien possible parce que même mais
je sais pas je ne sais pas c'est bizarre
que je sis il ya donc il y fait des fois
mais je passe trop qu'il y bien ils sont
petits ac45 tranquille et il peut jeu
pour faire nul avec son ac45 sans
prendre de risque et à ce moment là et
je voulais départageront la bon il prend
le risque de s'envoyer en l'air
alors je sais pas ce que ça donne mais
en rouge vois pas comment tu as plus de
chances de gain en jouant cette variante
avec les noirs que c'est une italienne
où je sais papa mais juste tu peux te
faire planter après mathieu dit que mam
ya joué à bosser avec griefs et wheel
drive tous adhèrent c'était la partie de
rien c'était un des deux mecs qui jouent
ça c'était contre éric in d'encan
toujours scotia ouais et du coup tu as
cette position analysé mathieu
je vais analyser ça
bon après j'ai pas à l'heure dite chasse
bonds' avec profondeur 26 ça veut rien
dire peut-être enfin elles sont vertes
40 un janot mais ouais en fait mais bon
clairement je vois pas ou avec les noirs
toujours la tête il espérait une autre
variante un autre truc ouais alors je
sais pas ce qui si vous je suis ni coop
sur calais b 5 bêta au 6e cool en fait
c'est un cas de figure où les blancs
soit il pendant ces six années font
qu'arriver 5 en gros tu as des petits
coups qui existe comme j'ai 3 à 3 vont
pas voir mais normalement soit tu
bouffes sais si tu veux 5 soit du fait
qu'il ait db5 là je vais pas bougé les
pieds à rennes en mai on va pas
s'embêter
ils vont pas comprendre on peut pas
faire les flèches concocterait que joue
la tchétchénie cov et point barre quoi
moi ou bas mais les cinq des six f4 5min
média coiffer tour juin que leur 10ème
temps pareil guide xt également en vue
ce fut encore plus rouge que le tailleur
bon écoute on verra plutôt rester chez
max mais pour l'instant tout pas qui
réfléchit après roy g2 donc ouais ouais
mec je sais pas si le verre de saké j'ai
essayé sous les sismo céder deux couples
je regarderai avec canards prennent à
peut-être d'autres ça se trouve tu peux
même jouer ces cinq ans un bar je sais
pas toi qui prends tous ici ça je prends
les capitales tive je ferai pas en fait
un problème humain et je sais pas trop
ce que tu acquis mais bon tu fais
peut-être là kg 6 10 ou je ne sais quoi
car il ya cinq ans nous prend sa c5 est
pas mais bon non mais t'as la paire de
fous un peu a filtré
tu fais tour h5 un jour c'était même pas
si idiot 2 pour sa cave si topalov ce
qu'il aime bien les trucs comme ça
durcit
c'est que ces 5 enfin moi j'ai faim je
serai bien j'aimerais bien jouer comme
ça donne quoi alors bien par le regard
des cavaliers points il regarde un puck
et prend ses plus étroits et j 6 6
il est 2 en faveur mais il ya bien oui
préfère les parents les deux mais cela
met en scène qui se bornent chef ossète
et tu t'en prends robe blanc très faible
franchement c'est pas étonnant que les
noirs sont donc ces cinq femmes
tu as eu le nez creux ces cinq c'est sa
part intéressant qui défonce et 6 et
alors on va pas prendre mais alors ok
autant faire ces 5 tu le fais de tempo
tu prépares tu es avec v6 tu fera
peut-être des sites sûrement b6 un jour
parce que s'il faut dire non si
berlinoise la casse et six mois la scène
fou qui va mais le roi est aussi très
bien c'est ça il est perchée bat a pas
d'échec des cavaliers et a plutôt que
deux manches
en fait personne ne touche alors
attentats tôt kravetz suivante au coupé
qui vont gérer riffier m'hamed j'avais
fou pranger 2 mai doute à cause de tour
âge et tout revient à venir c'était dans
le livre de votre eau niasse pour les
blancs au christ a dit qu'il l'avait
mathieu st cyr offerte
nul n'a pas eu l'oeil et jacqueline
culture de rognac mais je suis en 4
années à se laisser aller
il a fait un truc pour les blancs contre
nice je pensais qu'ils aient les
antilles sienne côté noir et je sais
qu'il a faits les livres sur
l'estonienne aussi mais ok bon choix
mais la fabrique pour les blancs aussi
tu te rappelles pas de quoi tu es
incroyable comme l'a dit oui ça prend
comment de l'esthétique le manque de
culture
la force de trop trop tôt de parler
kevin regarde ce qu'il devient n'allez
pas toi je pense à plutôt mamés et
l'autre non mais moi aussi un musée où
il va beaucoup nous on va encore dire
que oui il n'a même pas le livre de
comptines assure la main il aurait pu
chercher l'information tout le monde
sait que c'est écrit dans ce livre quoi
dès que tu apprends les règles du vivre
d'aidés des échecs tu as lu le livre de
coton iasc attacking flexible aussi
signale qu il a joué par six je sais pas
ce que c'est ce truc nul doper l'offre
quel manque de compréhension croyable
femme incroyable attacking the flag
sicilienne commenté
sais tu vas dire le bouc aqualand astic
je chanterai je suis en train de me dire
je le commande et peuvent donc b6 chaque
en mode full bluff ou quoi alma et
mathieu qu'il a bien évidemment fait un
petit clin d'oeil la chance chaque en
mode full bluff ou quoi mais je pense en
fait un que c'était du bluff normes
accueille une infante a du coup bah non
mais pas en france je sais douteux pour
la raison de chess bombe disait tu fais
tout rage 2 comme ça tu perds pas le
pion h4 et tour des géants feinte en
général et sai là il a refait un cours
ou choquer et détroit bon ça allait pour
lui après fou et 4 mai g5 de nouveaux
coups mais ajouté mme bonneau
mais soit je veux juste iv est parti
donc beaucoup plus qualitative que les
rats puisqu ils seront assortis de la
théorie et je te font dès lors lui avez
vu toutes les parties vont être fini en
une heure aujourd'hui on sait pas quoi
surtout que ce qu'ils réfutent ces
captures on prend les cinq balles dont
les romans pour qui la faisait 5 c'est
juste qu'il veut pas laisser la colonne
j'ai ouverte au blanc veut pas qu'ee de
torrents geste mais il joue tellement
vite en fait parce que je cours encore
matrix toi tu connais est ok je veux
bien croire mais ça a l'air douteuses
qui l'a fait parce que le lord issa
cotroni à ses amis dans son livre il va
pas écrit un livre à la main il va bien
pu leur nid cellini donc ça a juste la
relève du bluff
ils jouent tous tempo en bleu s'il faut
quoi ce coude appartient pas à ces deux
positions en distribution
c'est fantastique on a tous parlé comme
là tout le temps mais du coup couteau
pollock c b6 bonne nouvelle parce que
c'est un peu superflu second apparemment
après ce qu'on a vu on peut jouer ses
500 prépare avec b6 et ça crée des plus
de trucs weiner il faut cesti sous quoi
donc
bonne nouvelle après maintenant maxou
sais pas s'il va faire f 5 ou douchez
battu de develop keith et troy un coucou
dr bilbaski nous dit un truc sérieux pas
reconduit joue peut-être pas en bluff
peut-être qu'il confond avec une autre
position
oui ça c'est beau ça c'est possible
c'est plus sérieusement c'est possible
complètement pour toby je regardais c b6
jouer dans chaque partie au lieu de h5
même en correspondance pas sûr que ça
change enfin d'un point du bas tu as
envie de le faire un jour le 5 mai oui c
b6 100% un ailleurs avait fait ça et les
trois mecs par correspondance
cette bacata battu fait h5 un jour mais
en fait c'est sûr que une fois que t'as
pu besoin si cette façon c'est fait
c'est fait quoi fin du championnat rien
oui oui enfin si tu sais mieux se garder
la flexi quoi bas et si tous les mecs en
correspondance entre eux c'est que
sûrement objectivement mais six à
new-york où après cinq mois sans a pas
choqué qu'il a fait mais du coup du coup
je veux bien croire qu objectivement ce
soit moins bien et de le raser pour plus
tard pour des raisons
bah je sais pas en fait obscures bah
ouais profonde
en tout cas pour le moment fabuleux
scenario scénario rêvé fabre pour ce
premier tour n'est pas en danger ma met
en danger maxime mieux j'en ai pas dire
on n'a jamais été aussi proche d'une
qualif
parce que là si si maxime gagne avec
avec le point bonus je crois que c'est
la qualification et que les deux autres
écoutent ça va dépendre
mais est ce que son corps le sursaut
c'est qu'on est noir c'est deux points
la qualif
ouais 6 qualifie avec deux points
d'accueil celui frais 15 sauts et je
sais que peuvent encore mais bon ça va
commencer par les cheveux qui passent
quasiment tous les tours avec bonus et
qui gagne
ne serait pas mathématiquement fin mais
ça serait un énorme pas en avant
évidemment on aurait un pied et quatre
orteils au candidat basse et tu peux pas
rêver mieux ok rêver mieux c sont
éliminés et vos chats se câliner en plus
ou alors au moins il n'y avait pas de
bonus quoi au moins 100 bonus volta peut
finir à seize devrait donc mais bon oui
ça non mais non on n'y croit pas trop
mais ouais ok bon guérir déjà fait nul
du coup ils vendent et partage
ouais ce qui n'a pas perdu hier les mecs
midi à paris dans l'avion et tout venant
languir i dont un avion demain encore à
la cave et dvd de de lilas il adore avec
les f-35
bah ça peut même me tuait lucie jeanne
la berlinoise ma vraie tu me dis là
c'est fini
pas de chance non mais lille a le truc
c'est comme il un bon feeling des
positions sans réclamer un stade moins
un calcul fait quand même que des
grosses nage dans fou quoi n'est donc il
va bien peut être les pièces on voit
moins la règle de sofia dans les
tournants en ce moment dit paris zone
player en voix off on voit des règles
différentes si hélas aux grandes gestour
ali était dans la règle de sofia plus ou
moins il des gens ça enfin nous c'est ce
qu'on a pu penser comme et que proposait
jamais nulle mais en fait on sait pas ce
que j'aime bien que les tournois section
tu as du mal à connaître les règles face
est très difficile même pour tous les
gens qui corps en tout cas d'être la
règle du tournoi bat déjà sait jamais si
leurs noms mais surtout que c'est très
étonnant en fait de jetons à face à
cadence chaton a fait sa règle et ce
serait bien juste homogène enfin chacun
veut essayer après pourquoi pas mais qui
est déjà que les cadences sont pauvres
jeunes c'est même perturbant pour les
joueurs une fois tu joues avec 2h10
délai laissé ko
des fois tu as l'argent au 40e des
foyers tv 30 secondes par coup des fois
tu les as pas me 60e tu les as faim
c'est juste relookant fabrice qu'on peut
te faire un scud peut nous faire un
petit point
chrono pour la partie de maximum alors
max bien du temps une à 1h26 avant tout
du coup j'ai pas le prendre qui tourne
roula et topalov à 1h12 bon j'ai deux
joueurs ont un temps encore correct
ouais mais c'est vrai que enfin j'ai
envie dire évidemment on est pour maxime
et tout ça dans cette partie mais j'ai
envie de dire si mam et enée pause font
éliminer on prend aussi l'élimination
maxime quelque part oui la rivière je
prétends situe si on donne le cas de
figure où tu as maxi je préfère tout le
monde se qualifie mais pourquoi baille à
cause de soe
[Musique]
en fait si tu a plus personne dans le
tournoi so i er en gros ce qu ils sont
là ça veut dire qu'ils jouent vrai
qu'elle fonde en quarts peut passer avec
le point de bonus en demi je compte
gouttes à sec mais ils s'affrontent a dû
à la mort ils savent les [ __ ] en finale
puis tu te dis mais pas ce que je veux
dire en ligne il garde son destin en
main il joue pour se qualifier lui sans
attendre de prier qu'ils opèrent donc je
préfère que maxime se qualifie quitte à
ce que l'eau se qualifie en fait que
plutôt tourner vers quoi c'est génial et
sérieux comme ça qui sont ces cinq gros
quoi ces discours où je me fais me
nettoie aussi d'ailleurs ouvert tout
cela oui mais si je perds je n'ai plus
aucune chance de me qualifier c'est pas
grave
fais-moi confiance bien ce que je disais
quoi justement or valent plus que le
truc de malade le mieux quoi justement
justement à nantes qui disait que le
changement de cadence et pas à chaque
fois il n'était pas facile pour les
joueurs basse surtout qu'on confond pas
trop l'intérêt
je suis sûr c'est pas mal de jeunes ça
change pas mal en fait ce que quand tu
as les 30 secondes par coup tu peux te
mettre en faillite notent tranquille et
joue quelques coups ya pas de problème
quand tu es en délais déjà sûrement
jamais mais
du coup c'est une autre habitude tu as
plus de stress quand à plus de 10
minutes à la pendule enfin taux de
changes juste à la gestion du temps il
faut toujours toi réadapter genre je
veux dire quand tu vas jouer un ton
habitude rapidement à l'on doit
s'entraîner un peu avant faire des
parties amicales pour chauffer et il a
serait limitée en fait avant chaque
tomate voit trop chauffer un peu pour
pour la cadence que tu vas mal géré même
bouquet moi je change pas souvent de
cadence mais quand je fais la tournée en
espagne
il adore jouer avec l'alliance une heure
trente plus 30 secondes et c'est tout
c'est déjà hyper différents que quand à
linge au 40e bah oui c'est ça c'est
quand ils font des cadences long
classique il faudrait qu'il y ait une
cadence long classique une heure trente
plus 30 secondes et une demi heure au
40e quand elle est bien cette cadre un
exemple mais vient au pire on fait juste
le 1h38 30 secondes déjà six mois l'ont
les parties ça te laisse le temps de
bien jouer et voilà mais faut que ce
soit un peu de temps de chauffer que la
cadence est habitué prendre tes marquée
que chez ba enfin toute assez bien de
jouer très vite je sais papa tu peux
tenter de ton truc
enfin et comme à la formule 1 et sur une
stratégie à deux arrêts aux stands et il
est sur une stratégie où il fut très
vite mireille oui c'est un peu tout bon
jeu mais une petite page de pub d'une
minute balader comme ça ça personne ne
soit venu pourtant ouais non mais bon
c'est pour un pur inciter à s'abonner
justement voilà le fait bien en parler
si vous abonnez vous n'aurez pas de pub
la chance la pub est parti
non mais du coup j'aime bien ce que
matthieu 10 à propos de lille à un
cahier des deux kf3 ça va être un très
bon placement pièces du coup à toi tu
fais 5 tokayev 3 il est bien et défend
le saint qui couvrent ton roi le casa 4
1 pour que les cases et puis tu peux
aller bondir berger 5 ou faire du aussi
ce caillou 5,20 à plein d'idées acs a
l'air cool comme la seconde pièce très
que tu joues cas et c'est 3 à première
vue tu dis oui je me développe mais tu
vas vous quoi en fait t'as pas de rebond
nulle part la petite marche dessus
ouais c'est bien qu'elle ait d'octroi
très bien j'aime bien du coup la bonne
nouvelle c'est que c'est qu'il ya quoi
jouer est franc et franges et 5
oui mais la fête quoi d'autre bah tu vas
pas lu ses phares jezzine gk3 j'essaie
de trouver des bonnes nouvelles de
partout quoi non mais c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle en fait ce mamie vague
hélène je sais pas quel point il est mal
mais le pion g c'est un dangereux
criminel l'équivalent de 0,5 peu
paralysé avec les normes marrant comme
cette nuit passée quand même le tournoi
le plus important de l'année pour toi
machin est têtu oui mais et vous parlait
hier de révéler la tension ils l'ont
tout s'en va mais aussi tu as
l'impression que quelque part on n'est
pas connu pour pour chuck
non mais non mais germaine federer qui
semble hyper connus très fort
mentalement il en a peut-être site ilike
de suite perdue contre djoko ou 7
wimbledon il n'a pas tous les termes
acquis la part de finale comme ça parce
que je veux dire vraiment en fait
ok tu as beau être un monstre
dans la pression on aura tous humains
quand même donc une photo en temps tu
peux avoir un petit oubli
voilà toujours pas de coup côté max max
non non non ça réfléchit à moins que
j'ai un problème de mon côté ça
réfléchit mais écoute c'est bien qu'il
prenne son temps
sûr que là il doit chercher le meilleur
placement de pièces ou quoi et
franchement voilà que monde isa j'aimais
bien le cahier de machin que battu à
nous a dit nouveau coup rouge fable la
saison 4
non mais surtout il joue tellement vite
hyper hyper mais tant mieux mais je
remet à l'aller j'ai ridé joue là ni d'y
jouer des jeunes stars plus le leur dise
bien plus du hasard il te met quatre
lignes enfin hockey désolation de
stockfisch chercher ce bond ces 2 15 bon
on y croise de hockey jusqu'à français 5
qui est un couple de suite envie de
faire un pion tu le boost attaque 17
basse et plus de 0,4 et et après je suis
juste france 5 il encore à plus 1 23 car
tout ligue ou même 5 tu attends tu te
garde en réserve puisque le pion à j-5
va pas s'envoler
bon même ça qui paraît pas le coup plus
précis battait encore à plus 1 23 donc
c'est juste c'est gagnant mais ça fait
partie de ma vie
c'est étonnant non de faire de passer
comme de fer autour de la viande non
mais surtout de peut réfléchir non mais
c'est grotesque en fait j'aurais un
élève de 10 ans poussins quoi qui fait
ça je les engueule quoi il m'as tu
réfléchis car tu te trompes tu te
trompes tu vas pas jouer le tempo et je
veux que de la merde qu'on va chez makro
ccbc
c'est fantastique là mais bon après
qu'il ait resource pools faut faire
gaffe mais je pense cia coujoux bien en
fait tu as beau être autant sur soul que
tu veux c'est déjà trop tard
mais ils veulent en tunisie yacco qui a
le destin entre ses mains nom à
particule à ménimur rugbyman a dit qu'il
n'était pas intéressé par jour les
candidats bon mais entre ce qu'ils
disent est ce qui se passe il peut y
avoir
non mais au pire il peut être malade lui
aussi vient pas alors ben c'était pile
billard il a essayé de gagner quand même
n'a pas fait nul en cinq ou six ans ici
mais par miracle n'est pose quelles
filiales et gp l'autre russe a
directement la wild card bah oui oui
juste qu'il sera le seul russe elise en
fait peut-être masoe sortie à fond avec
moi même avec ma vie il ya eu oui j'en
fais une grosse soirée bien sûr vase ou
et là je ne peux pas rater cette soirée
extraordinaire bah oui c'est impossible
de grandir d'agrandir les images de
l'échiquier à droite c'est pas facile
n'y a pas beaucoup de place après je
vais essayer d'en faire un tout petit
peu plus mais mais mais c'est difficile
on peut essayer de de rogner de partout
battus pour renier cet enlèvement des
joueurs mais ces gens vont comprendre
les gens qui sont là en ce moment à qui
on parle de ses bons ils vont bien
comprendre les nouveaux arrivants sur le
sur le live et onze heures tu sais quoi
cet échiquier à droite à lormont voit on
voit ce que ça c'est de vraiment
optimisé
allez un peu j'ai même un peu pris sur
les ombres et tout mais là plus que ça
on peut pas voilà lille saint just le
monde maxime ou quoi ou pas pour qu'il
l'accompagné bas c'est plus morale en
fait après six matchs regard d'une
variante il peut quand même demander son
avis à celles des grands maîtres ils
peuvent un avis mais je pense que niveau
prépare après pas il est pas là pour
juste les et chaque fois c'est plus être
un soutien moral
tony de faim c'est cool on va de ne pas
défendre à tout seul alors quelqu'un qui
tient compagnie qui tue au resto le soir
il y avait qui tu peux faire des
activités qui de baisse la pression
nerveuse quoi ça serait bon en fait on
est juste allé pour déconcentrer mal
mais pas aussi en fait les grosses
soirées à jérusalem bis ou die club avec
mam mais ici ils sont à fond quoi mais
là j'ai vu ils ont joué un jeu de
une sorte de mélange de puissance 4 et
de dames en quelque sorte
ah oui ils ont joué à ce jeu riche j'ai
vu sur ses instincts à traduire ce jeu
ouais comme ça vous gêne je trouve être
le gym à discussion ça s'appelle
paradoxe ah ouais c'est très chaud comme
je mets que pour bouger en fait tu
bouges ta boule plus que si une boule
adverse à côté que tu la pousse ouais
j'ai une boule blanche ou bleue
donc c'était ça la prépa en fait un jeu
difficile
l'afab comment ça se passe bien mais a
pris hier ça se passait très mal et puis
ça s'est bien fini donc faudrait pas
aujourd'hui que ça commence bien et que
ça finisse mal non nobles aux personnes
mais là vraiment vite surtout mme amel
hakim qui me donne envie de perdre là
bas même à mes mamies tilt et justes ni
peau du cou mais il s'est pris au 5 et
puis je sais combien c'est
extraordinaire car je suis encore
vraiment dans le mammy le plus grave je
joue c'est là aussi que tu te rends
compte de la force d'un mec comme
caruana parce qu'on a le championnat du
monde il a quasi pas de choc oui bah ya
qu une partie où il a raté machin petit
peu mais sinon il a été ultra solide
dans la tête
bon match à jouer ces quatre îles pas du
tout joué le plan le plan précités
ouais mais ça a l'air pas mal quand même
mais en fait là du coup ça retourne dans
les particules response c'est en fait
j'ai fait d'autres ordres de coûts non
b6 d'abord machin mais ça tombe pile
poil dedans et les deux packs
responsable fait qu'ali g6 ici donc c4
c4 moins bien que tout le reste n'est
que le conte est arrivé depuis des
plombes
ça va aller ça vous pouvez le dire dans
le chao ou alors ils peuvent lancer un
stream
oui je suis je suis je suis d'humeur
espiègle n'ont donc ces cas de mathieu
il nous dit la raison c'est que si les
normes ou c5 et ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire en général cette donne une assise
en d5 focalise ses trois cahiers dessin
c'est logique mais dont kg si si si
c'est le coup hyper logique bon déjà les
mecs ont joué par correspondance pour
commencer mais en au bataclan et sortir
le fouet fuite
vu que ces cinq ça devient moins à
l'ordre du jour du cac et ses trois
cahiers des 5 tu te rend un peu sur le
pion là pour ce qui est la réalité de
aussi par la même occasion m non mais
c'est bien un ticket juste ça t'évite f5
donc si jamais tu veux faire fou 17 un
jour pour les taper sur g4 h3 sur cette
diagonale pour l'instant toutes fermées
la vue par f5
au moins avec le clergé 6 bat encaissé 5
quoi ce très logique il ya peuvent elles
qui demandent si ce que les blancs peu
joué ces cinq un moment où eux mêmes bon
écoute pourquoi pas non je pense que
c'est pour compresser les nordistes leur
fou 8 mauvais mais comme pour l'instant
fait l'énorme lasse pas de faire ces 5e
même je le garde en réserve qu'on sait
c'est un calcul mais pas le faire dans
un lointain futur nom dans un lointain
futur
un jour peut-être est-ce que j'irai à
moins jouer cette année pour maintenir
son lots oh oui bah oui mais pas tout le
long en satin
c'est à dire qu'au début il a joué très
normalement sur la fin de saison et d'un
budget mais pas se comprendre
c'est génial que les mecs dans le tchad
duchess bon bilan sur les choix ils
disent que avoir mené pour candidat
parce qu'ils seraient là je ne vais pas
dire le mot de tous les joueurs qui ont
un peu comme aaron hill a donné la
parole à partir de la comète comme avait
dit rêver de nouveau la rogne entre les
jambes extraordinaires
désolé que ça n'a pas de rapport avec la
partie et juge lit ça ça me fait marrer
heureusement que notre chatte est
beaucoup moins toxiques aux usa et qui
n'est pas passée toxiques cette chatte
et on disait qu'on retarde chaises
barrant la lie de l'humanité mais je ne
lis pas d'habitude ce que j'ai pas
besoin de l'ouvrir juste là j'ouvre par
hasard checkez en fait si tu lis écouter
juste pas arrivé naturellement
ouais j'ai checké froidevaux est remonté
à samedi non mais jean roch et pour les
parties lentes on s'en fout un peu mais
dès que ça te les rapides les départage
c'est un peu plus un problème
non je vais faire remonter kg 6 joué par
un parent topito pas logique
et j'imagine qpc trois à suivre mais
mais du coup il pourra se développer
pousse à toujours revenir en dix-sept
donc être fou pour commencer un peu
avisé g4 et du coup de frein plus de
prendre cinq ou sept pas clair un schéma
qu on me demande si ma m pères et mvl
pas son sabre le champagne c'est mon nom
je crois pas en fait parce que même si
les poèmes avait perdre et qui marque
deux points il passera à 15 mais voilà
c'est qu'à 5 donc si vous êtes à cette
page les bonus ipr encore bon après si
vos cheveux secs peur ils sont aussi là
tu sabres tools la tue sa brume c'est un
coup d'épée là tu vas directement tout
cas on s'approche
ben hammam est en tout cas une bonne
crise notre position n'est pas yves
heller après on verra on peut se faire
un bon le truc c'est qu'il est moins
bien mais que c'est ça reste compliqué
et il peut tout voir un hacker revient à
la partie
ok mais c'est beaucoup moins fait que
les peaux que ma mais voilà après les
autres écoutons vérins déjà max
consommation savoir ticket 6-3 jouer
mais évidemment ça ça peut aussi enlever
de la pression à max de voir que les
autres font un peu n'importe quoi c'est
plutôt bien ah ouais bah c'est relaxant
mais
non mais la partie de ma mais je pense
qu'elle est vraiment importante aussi
parce que ça fait vraiment du bien de le
voir dehors voyez dans les mains mais en
plus c'est clair que c'est a pas trop de
contrôle sur lui c'est il n'est pas dans
ton tableau et s'ils viennent tous les
matches en fait tu aurais une finale
contre lui dans le cas où cuisine tout
aussi ou faux papas donc oui c'est ça
ouais et puis en plus un joueur qui a un
petit qui a besoin de se mettre en forme
et quand ils se chauffent après il peut
être rien rétable donc c'est bien qu'ils
s'arrêtent tout de suite en fait tout
seul
elle n'a jamais été chaud et du froid
dommage ce que tu penses qu'à une vielle
regarde les autres partis de loin non il
doit je tenais quand même généralement
oui oui il m besson la même pièce en
fait donc tu vas pas rester assis tout
le longe un tutu qui tourne je regarde
un peu même sans vouloir puissance avoir
juste par curiosité thuriau tu te fais
nos mini mini petite pause vas-y et je
reviendrai dans la foulée mathieu gaye
oui et non il doit trop regarder les
autres partis ça doit pas trop organe
non mais bon ils peuvent être peut-être
un petit coup d'oeil voit bien que mam
est en danger nord matthieu arthur dj
qui lui celui qui doit être heureux en
voyant tout ça c'est gritche quoi la
grille de chou qui doit être
il doit être aux anges un parce que si
mam et perd peut-être qu'il est déjà
qualifiée parce que nés peau et mvl ils
sont dans la même partie de tableau donc
ils pourront pas aller tous les deux en
finale donc grille tout qui est
peut-être très proche de la qualif là il
est très proche
la qualif la grille tchouk donc là doit
être très heureux du développement mais
cou rouge de la part de mam est bon mais
pas très rouge quoi il reste à + 1 60
donc ça va être sûr qu'à rédiger ici si
si les noirs retire le cavalier il
compte faire fouquereau h5 superposition
iakovenko bon après faut se méfier mam
est qui qui est bon dans les positions
dynamique qui voit pas mal de petites
tactiques il peu l'arnaqué
faut faire gaffe si amérique gré allegri
tout con 15 points c'est quoi le
départage c'est celui qui a gagné le
plus de grand prix
donc ce serait maigri tous qu il a plus
de 15 points en gris tout qu'il a 20
points en six mois mais perd ça laisse
plus de place aux russes théoriquement
je sais pas dans quel sens se disent à
paris qca 20 points mais si maxime et
gris tout con 20 points ces grilles tube
qui passe si tout le monde
alien shooter partie la fédé russe à
l'europe de sa place à un russe non ça
ne pourront pas le faire je vais au tour
de quoi non à des gens qui continuent à
s'en prendre à la fédé russe parce
qu'ils ont arrêté à varennes en reste et
hallucinant quoi oui se doit pas non
plus
non mais c'est vrai j'ai très envie de
troller la prochaine fois qu'il ya un
grand thiès sort en france où kouassi
danois et le gardien français oui
comment est ce possible
écoutons pataugeoire donne les mêmes
machines artisans de penser ce que vous
voulez il n'y a pas eu de coups l'un il
était fausse note que iakovenko a aucun
intérêt à gagner la partie
oui et non mais bon par contre ça
topalov aucun intérêt à gagner la partie
faire un nom mais en fait au plus bas au
canada
et là tu es là quoi fait des couilles tu
joues pour gagner enfin si tu joues un
jeu pour que tu joues mais ce serait
beau quand arrive aux grandes chaînes je
sais pas quoi hier soir j'ai joué au
mini ping pong
ces gars là j'ai au canada a gagné non
plus bon bah il se trouve que j'ai c'est
de gagner quand même on mardi je voulais
jouer à la belote mais j'ai envie de
gagner
non mais sinon il ya plus d'intérêt de
rien du tout jamais dans la vie enfin
aujourd'hui mais en fait pourquoi vous
jouez tous aux échecs et moi le premier
aussi on ne peut pas le candidat bout
d'un projet en fait je ne sais pas j'ai
arrêté de jouer d'ailleurs non mais bon
pourquoi 12 arena peuvent attribuer aux
candidats c'est quel est l'intérêt
je suis sùr imams salut sinon je vais
faire stream du coup il a joué et a
dissous le 7 mai la fausse note bon
normal il se développe alors moi mais au
personnage comme ça quand tu auras fou
17 tu te rendras plus non plus 2 kg 5
aujourd'hui je tripe le montant même
triplement bien joué alors oui la
matière jean n'est pas là même s'il n'a
pas une qualification je n'en remets ça
c'est mais on est d'accord mais bon je
trouve qu'une voie que tu es là tu es là
et c'est d'autant mieux de jouer le jeu
à fond
que de refuser de venir ou de faire des
bilans trois coups et partir ça montre
que tu respectes le jeu tu vas tu avec
le tournant a tu respectes les
spectateurs juste tu respectes mais a en
réalité tu vois le genre même iakovenko
fait on quand on entend les joueurs de
premier plan jean guy et où je peux
comprendre de dire ça
autant iakovenko de toute façon il vient
jouer juste un tournoi il a invité nulle
part en fait pour lui c'est un gros
tournoi
non mais il fait sa partie cofosa et que
ça va changer sa vie de gagner ou pas
mais une fois que tu es là tu as pris
ton billet d'avion qui s'étaient
déplacés et ben pourquoi tu as avec
optimus qui jusqu il peut avoir une
contrepartie financière dans les
coulisses c'est ce qui veut dire oui
mais topalov aussi qui te dit que tu opa
que maxime a pas chez la partie avec toi
topalov danser caressions rentrer là
dedans
oui dans ces cas là n'est pas chez la
partie peut-être à guelph andes
non mais dans après le truc c'est que
vous pouvez voir le mal partout mais
c'est comme un goret et paco et chaque
camp fait après non mais le truc c'est
que c'était comme en coupe du monde
quand made in contre hewit dit oui à le
laisser gagner
jacques avait il faut candidats bon il
se trouve que non oui c'est toujours
possible en fait mais pas tout est
possible mais bombages utilisons jeu de
jeu d'ailleurs bravo à leurs fans non
mais ça existe dans les échecs toi même
tu le sais la mine mais bien sûr je le
sais que ça existe dans les échecs mais
je veux dire par là que ça existe dans
tous passé
et voilà mais même moi j'ai une anecdote
en cyclisme quand enfin c'est un truc
bracquemont vraiment raconter qu'icône à
quoi s'était à l'époque on ne vire ans
que je jouais pour gagner le maillot
quoi avec ulrich quettehou et je sais
plus une fois une étape ou riche il est
pas bien il arrive à s'échapper
l'iran qu'il ait montagny et je sais pas
c'était un petit groupe
et puis ok donc il passe un premier col
et redescendre dans la vallée et pis
t'as un long tronçon quoi peut-être une
cinquantaine de kilomètres jusqu'à la
prochaine montée evian bus qui roule et
puis les autres reprennent pas trop le
relais il ya pantani ben vas-y pas roule
on y voit ses 10000 badwill au canada un
rôle précis joué par willem tour il faut
que je gagne l'étape odieux pas de
griller dans la plaine il veut voir ses
jambes dans la dernière ascension quoi
bah ouais ok bah il n'a pas roulé et ils
sont fait reprendre et puis je trouve
plus riches à gagner le tour
la fin de ces trois semaines mais ok
coiffe assez juste vous pouvez voir ça
partout c'est tout pareil dans tous les
sports hockey ayant vu là je l'aï va
rien se passer d'eux comme ça mais la
russie à coventry la 1 + 1 60 il a une
position gagnante jouera pas pendant la
partie mam est allé voir ya qu il dire
ouais je peux jouer cavalier 5me
l'emprise les joueurs sont quand même
assez faire s'est il n'y a pas trop de
soucis là dedans dans les échecs ça se
passe quand même assez bien mais voilà
donc bref un jeu dire non c'était juste
une anecdote est une parmi 10 millions
voilà c'est tout donc bref pas il faut
quand même faire confiance aux joueurs
et pas voir le pire tout le temps
imagine bien sûr surtout que
je sers du pire arrive très rarement
enfin géré par là comme on l'a dit les
deux joueurs chinois qui se connaît
c'est tout ça il n'y a pas eu de
problème là dans les grands prix enfin
tu vas au grand prix précédent dépôts et
ses gammes éliminé au premier tour
un moment donné faut pas faux pas faut
pas voir le mal partout les amis mais
mathieu il viendra fille claudine il
sait pas si clair ma mère renonce à tout
projet sylvain qui nous vaut une petite
variante
ça a l'air chiant mais ça doit tenir
peut-être sur un jeu précis galfond de
bien jouer
oui bien ce que je disais fourrage 5 to
ils sont toute analyse alors 10e et
galfond de when the saints beaujoire qui
trichent quoi un exode qui te citer qui
écrit il se situe à patrie il ya de la
triche partout mais faut pas le voir le
mal partout que non mais potentiellement
de pieds-noirs pas non mais je sais pas
même si tu as quelqu'un l'entreprise
peut-être il été pistonné enfin je suis
pas après tu aimes guérini est qu à
défaut bottes parnaudeau la mairie ni
utile vous avez quitté cris faut pas
voir le mal partout c'est ce que
quelqu'un qui est dans le coup dirait un
petit peu de cas pas de partout aux
normes et le tournoi sont assez faire en
général là sur les grands prix tout ça
va ça va donc vacciner à temps maxime et
des couilles et lui [ __ ] normal bons
fous des satires logique je dirais pour
presser un peu les pions et loin irwin
ça mais oui en tout cas ce que pour
revenir juste voir ja il ya quand même
et il n'est plus en tout cas ils font
pas des grosses parties
après je ne sais pas ça de sa finale du
coup tous les deals du tout les doutes
sont sur amazon pourquoi mazoyer allait
bien fois c'est des mecs
mazeau venu avec le chéquier serait
génial et qu après qu'ils aient perdu il
va les voir so i watch taceq copain jo
maso a pris un beau prix au tournoi de
londres
tout s'explique coïncidence je ne crois
pas quoi donc
donc on va falloir repartir avec une
énorme monde romain met à écrire c'est
très suspicieux sont ces cinq à la place
de d5
voilà tout s'explique
et au maintenon mais c'est pas que là un
max franchement c'est pas j'étais plus
confiant avec lequel des deux kf3 mais
c'est elle hilare non mais l'après-foot
17 je sais pas c'est pas c'est pas enfin
les nerfs sont solides quoi c'est pas
net
mais bon ce qui advient ce fait que les
autres sont en crise
ma mère est sa partie elle est quand
même incroyable
la partie d'eux-mêmes et affable bon
vous en fait c'est possible que cela te
fait quoi enrager trois noms chez max
chez max voiturage et 3 ne donnerait un
petit fou h4 tu t'en vas je repars en
recettes moi j'ai de leurs 10 x et
wimereux front va dire mais c'est un peu
chiant que ce sont eux les retours du
fou que ce que je te menace avec la
courage trois échecs tout fait j'ai
quatre peut-être tu dois refaire range
étroit et vu les circonstances femme est
ce que n'eut finalement c'est pas juste
un bon résultat ici tu es pour rien non
mais je me tue à accueillir toute façon
parce que tu aimes tu joues pas la
qualifie que prêter les départage ami si
tu prends pas annuler tu laisses les
autres mourir tu reste en vie quoi le
but survivre
moi je survis
toi t'es pas le morceau elle n'était pas
marrant de cela j'ai tenté de la gala
elle n'a pas marché ça semble marcher à
était pas terrible mais j'ai tenté j'ai
tant de là il a tout il fait le jw une
femme atteignait un niveau gm y sommes
amis en a il y en a plein comme albert
sera-t-il autorisé parti autorisé vote à
weissach circuit mixé par un circuit
maximum un jeu tout de suite oui je veux
tout de suite c'est un circuit accusés
bien que le circuit féminin qui exclut
les hommes mais le circuit mx1 q les
femmes sur ça c'est un toit mixant toi
timing c'est une compétition mixer pas
une petite compétition masculine
c'est quand même important de le
souligner voilà et salua grand oeuvre
dans le tchat
je ne vois pas que par la fin je me fous
17 h ou 17 ans encore joué et d'allonger
ses bâches dressées sur l'échiquier
peut-être pas encore ça paraît tellement
logique aussi qua non il n'a pas joué
exact c'est pas facile en n'ayant pas
c'est vrai les parties s'est un peu fait
pas le truc n'est pas lui qui aurait dû
jouer les candidats du modem elle les a
joués en feutre le tournoi un mexique
l'an 2005 et à quoi elle a été 10e 10e
joueur ou joueuse puisse pas comment
dire mondiale non mais c'était très
forte
oui bien sûr
vous avez battu le record de précocité
pour le titre de gmi on reste détenu par
fisher et paul garein lui avant quand je
sais pas j'avais quinze emplois je pense
14 14 ou 15 ans bon depuis c'est encore
descendu plus bas de la séance fonseca
yakine qu'il a avec 12 ans et huit mois
et puis bon ce sera encore battu un de
ces quatres toute façon mais peu importe
mais ça te montre juste le niveau cela
ne fait pas très vive cette ouverture du
circuit masculin aux fans c'est pas un
circuit masculin c'est un circuit mix
déjà moi je vois que des visites dans
les plateaux mais non en fait c'est par
exemple s'il y avait dix femmes qui
était numéro 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
mondial y aurait que des femmes
là il se trouve qu'il ya que des âmes
mais c'est pas en mode
parité 55 femmes c'est au mérite en fait
c'est ma flûte et on regarde pas en fait
c'était un homme une femme ou quoi
justement n'y a pas de différence on dit
voilà on est tous au même niveau on est
tous à égalité sur ce circuit si c'est
les femmes qui sont plus forte voir que
des femmes c'est que des hommes on la
parle alors en l'occurrence c'est le cas
ça va être que des hommes mais il n'y a
pas si si tu es une femme et que tu as
le niveau il ya personne qui va te
fermer des portes c'est mêmes linverse
d'ailleurs willy fans elle avait été
prise bon un peu raide l'iphone les
grands prennent des grands prix et tout
ça donc il n'y a pas pas du tout de de
fermeture à 6 voilà exactement c'est
vraiment haut niveau et au mérite de
tout un chacun sans regarder ce à quoi
voilà lorsque l'on fait la numéro un
mondiale féminine donc c'est oui fans
jeunes chinoises qui maquillent fortin à
2664 lots mais classement mixte sané 84e
2 mondial donc là en fait on regarde un
tournoi quand c'est les ans et les
grandes chez ce tour bon ben ça soit
vous pleinement les dix meilleurs
joueurs mondiaux
ben oui quand 84e mondial en fait t'es
pas dans les dix et là les grands prix
fidh
bon bah ils ont pris 21 joueurs mais
quand 84e n'est pas dans l'es21 non plus
jusqu'à la 50e place mondiale
et merci à geoffroy la corne qui a pris
un seul j'avais une petite pub
il n'a pas été très heureux
pourquoi galfond ne jugeait pas qu'il
ait des six échecs rapidement at il
ajouté des 6es ouais il de jouer et il
est très bien mais ok c'est pas fini
parce que y'a rien en plus mon épaule va
se démener il est ici de gigoter dans
une position difficile mais il s'est
trouvé des ressources il n'est pas
facile non plus à abattre donc j'attends
encore gagné mais écoute en tout cas
c'est cool parce que qu'elle fondait
très bien yacco et très bien cela est la
taupe qui nous trottent dans le chat
donc on va parfois plus loin à lui un
petit coup de pub away écoute non mais
faut qu'on la passe de toute façon la
pub donc
il a eu la pub en plus à geoffroy malgré
l'abonnement bref la bastille donc alors
tour des stades tour des stades tour des
stades donc à aider six jouer donc
galfond mieux mais comme tu disais c'est
un peu c'est un peu un peu les joues
même s'il que topalov maxime hier quoi
c'est à dire que garmin mieux mais n'est
pas né peut il peut te faire glisser
mais oui pour ta son enfant le scénario
est très bien après 1h22 austère que
maxime bon tuto un poil mieux enfin
peut-être plus mais pas de risque et mam
est née peau en grand danger après ou
est ce les sauts bon écoute c'est une
partie mais il est un peu mieux je pense
contre liu parce que botha lapeyrère de
fou déjà c'est quelque chose que voilà
et lojack nos tasses et qui cessera de
boston qui dès les noirs probable nul
non je ne sont pas contents et mis la
pub pendant qu'on parlait mais bon le
truc c'est qu'on fait pas de pause donc
à un moment donné a forcément on va tout
le temps parler fr a vu qu'on fait un
stream un peu vivant et on essaie de
bouger on se coupe même la parole avec
rafa je te coupe la parole assez souvent
mais du coup on était tout le temps de
parler d'un truc un autre tu vois de
rebondir donc forcément il ya toujours
un truc qui se passe en fait plutôt donc
donc voilà
ça se passe pas trop mal c'est pas trop
mal pas vraiment demander mieux que roy
g7 joué par mam et à l'instant j'essaie
de rester le coût normal de que le
meilleur coup crois que tu nous dises
matthieu lahaye là pourquoi ils disent
tu es tour des franges et d'israël il
faut prendre 6 3 projets 6 3 et 4 qui
peut être logique leur dis aime pas trop
ratant je peux mettre la ligne quand il
ya des lignes d'eau redis je peux les
faire bouger social indoor dit malgré je
peux comprendre sacs soient pas gagnant
va souffrir après bon écoute ci sauf
cette partie mammadyarov renvoie lui
mais moins bien je me sens pas non mais
j'ai peur il a juste vraiment raté
l'ouverture et c'est spécial quoi mais
pourquoi faire fou pranger sinon je
montrais juste que vous prendrez si
c'était pas terrible donc vaut mieux ne
peut faire pour le coup n'est pas dans
de meilleures conditions je ne sais pas
mais j'avais juste quand même coup franc
j'ai 6 ans fait et c'est un gros
avantage de faire ça mais le truc en
fait c'est clean que l'ordi donne je la
trouve pas simple tour déjà faut bien
entre l'impression bien comprendre pas
parfait tallinder dit jamais j'aurais
peut-être je comprends que tu veux
prendre j'ai six cercueils 5 et penser
c'est prendre 6 mais bon surtout qu'il
ne fait pas après ça fait roi prend elle
te fait pas cavalier e 5 à pascal roy
échec à la fin juillet parce qu'il fait
tard je fasse et que des coups compliqué
fait un tour pour j'évite aussi c'est
assez dur à convaincre les nouveaux
trouvable ouais enfin une fois que tu
l'as vu c'est toujours trouvable parce
que tu trouves une logique mais pour y
penser de base wef à ce jeu c'est pas
impossible mais sa demande mais aucun
nouveau là comme le disait mathieu dans
le chat c'est juste position encore
assez compliqué pour les bleus en fait
il ya un 70
est ce qu'un jour envers un trio pour
analyser avec jean raph la des fables en
fait n'aime pas trop les trios ça marche
pas très bien en fait les trios on a
déjà remarqué que quand un effet sa
femme l'avait on avait eu fait c'est
ouais bon pote bas avec poulou ouais
mais c'est très difficile
alors en fait je pense il est sur un
plateau tous vont aller en même temps
peut-être oui la distance le tombé et je
pense vraiment sur un plateau pas devant
un écran pour commenter la partie forum
soit un plateau un vrai plateau pour que
les gens puissent parler s'installer
faire des chroniques un peu car effet
avec winamax tv pas quelqu'un qui anime
et qui qui relance qui posent des
questions et après tu as genre deux
chroniqueurs qui rebondit ça c'est
faisable mais offert un commentaire de
partie c'est difficile
cassany mais aujourd'hui le fab du coup
tout est parti ce matin on vers un derby
ça bouge ça fait pas des petites nul
c'est plus animé qui a déjà ses colonnes
et eux ils ça peut bien se passer
as tu pris imagine un set up comme pour
les grands prix avec un gars qui est
juste là pour montrer des lignes en deux
temps entendu je n'aime pas trop ça tape
là perso et en plus ça demande des
moyens qu'on n'a pas ça moi sache la cua
en fait non mais écoute pourquoi pas je
sais pas mais oui cela demande des
moyens pas déjà fait un écran plat vous
pas qu'il faut casser au pouvoir oui
enfin c'est compliqué il faut vraiment
avoir une régie le cv quoi me faisant
une régie du pouce et après c'est pas un
mec en plus ces deux mecs en plus une
salle et une installation de ouf
mais tout ça pour bouger des coûts sur
un écran une fois de plus de niort et
pas avoir une once de 1200 personnes
mais 1203 regarde donc c'est beaucoup de
moyens pour un truc qui est qui à mon
sens est pas faite gens que si j'avais
de l'argent à investir pour faire
quelque chose ce serait pas ça en fait
donc
donc il dit juste un skype est un mec
qui monte des lignes sur un écran
connecté un site que tu spectacle peu de
moyens faut avoir un skype en plus
ouverts en même temps qu'ils ont la
qualité de l'audio le machin n'ont
clairement pas je vois pas l'intérêt que
tu bouges les pièces comme ça avec une
souris sur un échiquier pour te montrer
digne de leur dit que les deux on peut
allumer leur 10e dire les cousines la
joie paulo ouais bof non difficile par
contre faire un vrai par la télé une
émission ça peut être sympa mais une
nouvelle fois c'est beaucoup de moyens
pour pas grand chose donc c'est dur donc
après c'est pas forcément une mauvaise
idée non plus mais juste c'est très
difficile techniquement à faire pour pas
grand chose donc donc du fou ou trois
bons on attend goût quand j'achète
toujours qu'il soit sûr de chasse bon ou
pas non on y va je suis docteur 10 et
des moyens juste pour avoir l'air
progressé plus ça met du coup non mais
si tu les as tu les as août ont utilisé
je veux dire mais c'est chaud à mettre
en oeuvre et ça ne change pas
fondamentalement le fond
ouais ouais non mais qu'est ce que ça
vaut le coup c'est françois rivard de
progrès mais c'est toujours pareil sans
vie de m quinze mille euros pour avoir
l'air pro sur un tournoi c'est non mais
après ce buzz je suis tellement tous les
moyens après ils font ce qu'ils veulent
we dare écran qui qui on voit 15 8 en
local et enfin lui wen ont clairement
clairement clermont mais je parlais
d'entrer dans la logique d'avoir ta
quant à ta propre chaîne switcher tout a
déjà du mal à ah ouais mais là c'est
oublier enfin clairement pense que ça
arrivera jamais
j'ai déjà des jardins du mal à payer les
montages de ludwig j'imagine mais l'art
est sérieux on arrête les montages
pendant deux ans parce que sur ce
tournoi on voudra voir on voudrait
vraiment avoir un mec qui passe des fois
sur twitch pour pour dire les coûts de
leur dit quoi je fonce alfort et pas
trop rayon d'à c'était génial de la
foulée qu à l'oreille en problème
j'imagine le discussions élitiste je
suis mal quoi tu auras dégouté hills où
michael devant l'ordi donc bonjour tour
des stones mais mes coups de gueule font
ça déconne pas mal et vida qui dit
pourquoi voilà apprend alors qu'on peut
avoir l'air écho plus exactement on peut
pas le faire on peut pas le faire pas
grave
une idée que je peux prendre un ipad 2
mais là je te bouges les trucs hills ou
non après c'est cool comme moi je suis
d'accord avec millions soit en soit
avoir le troisième est quettehou
franchement franchement c'est bien
franchement ça ça apporte un petit plus
pour pourparlers complètement
sérieusement mais moi en fait je me
mettais dans la tête par rapport à moi
ma chaîne par rapport au budget qui
avait tout ça et je me dis c'est juste
irréalisable par rapport aux eaux à la
plus value que sa porte en fait c'est
nous que je pensais comme ça comme ça ça
devrait après après si tu as les moyens
de le faire c'est bien mais dans une
logique de faire quelque chose qui
réussit ou quoi faut pour faire ce genre
de truc procès c'est plus une petite
chaîne chez toi dans ta chambre et tous
faut quand même avoir à notre niveau
d'aidé
les ressorts notre des retours
financiers en fait sinon sinon ça vaut
pas le coup pas pour nous ça vaudrait
pas le coup
c'est quand même ce pont de sawtche s
comme moi mais tu fais comme je pense
pas que il est l'objectif d'envoyer
15000 par tournoi pour avoir un mec avec
une caméra ça c'est déjà on a du mal à
récupérer des budgets pour pour tout
commenté avec des costes et tout ça
c'est c'est un petit peu un petit peu
compliqué quoi mais le mariage nous
envoyer un e aide et c'est ce qu'ils ont
dit merci maria il ya encore une marge
qui te hau sse voilà c'est la classe
merci je veux un poste la chanson just
my small sens qui vous feriez store day
trade avec un petit coeur merci merci
allumé des petits coeurs de partout et
tout ça ça c'est beau tu vois ça c'est
beau j'en veux dire bravo voilà là les
gens sont très heureux
merci photos de chasse
elle a appris le français tu as l
apprend déjà le français très vite
coffret jt 12 jui l'élite l'élite va
revenir me voir taupier jouer robin sa
teneur ne peuvent se fonder cette tour
des huit doit pas être un mauvais coup à
ma foi mais
le tofu 17 et m'avait l'air intéressant
assez logique qui était vrai qu'on loupe
pas si tu me dire mais bon ben on avait
sept quelque part c'est pas son nom ni
les bus était content tu caches ton roi
tu peux faire tour des huit peut-être tu
feras c5 au moment opportun
donc pourquoi pas mais il veut justement
ces 5 pouces et 6 clairement un du coup
mais bon ça toujours pas résolu le
problème du tronquay des cinq peut-être
que veut dire qu'est ce que tu fais avec
les blancs quoi oui bien sûr mais bon
vous êtes fous des statuts pose la même
question d'attaquer j'ai 4 passes et
puis les routes attaquer ces cas du coup
le mec il savait ce qu'il faisait quand
il protège avec 4 bat pour protéger car
texte qui complète un petit roger 3 à
bientôt à bientôt maria va bientôt faire
on te fais des bisous
j'ai envoyé un bisou j'ai envoyé un
bisou on te fais des bisous
on veut l'envoyer des raids des compotes
est 13h effet trésorerie rabais si tu
écoutes
ouais en fait je suis passé très
compliqué ce genre de positions dures de
sa régression ce qui se passe le date on
peut me songer à par kg 3 kf5 est-ce que
ça ça peut être intéressant quoi ah non
ça mène à rien bref deux palmarès du
cavalier j'ai fait un échec
ouais il est mal après owen je peux
accuser g3 m'a pas l'air bilan soit un
salaire assez intéressant non comme coup
mais wen ont jeté un oeil tout à l'heure
dans la partie a résumé fo 17 ce que ça
donne à quoi vous et ça c'est
intéressant un jeu d sa 3g transport
hyper logique il faut h 4 bref trois
fous aux 7 quai juste ce que tu as mieux
que nulle que tf2 préfère améliore le 4
mai peut-être six mamans par exemple
apparaît c'est hyper logique un fab non
mais ok pour la tient pour l'instant je
ne sais pas j'ai pas la réponse quand je
peins lorsqu'elle a fait roi beyssade ou
tant mieux
ici tu dois jouer tout rachat aux
cavaliers à vue de nez ça pour les noirs
et des projets éco détourage 4 j'imagine
a dit qu'on n'a pas le temps de faire re
3 500 formateurs en fait donc tu vois
pas de courage quatre ans m du coup mais
quoi
et si ceux ci précise aux epci sa non
adhésion et roger 3 km h quatre longues
et 6 5 e 6 6 2 6 et la cerise de qualité
nathan est ce qu'on est obligé parce que
ravi prévenus à temps sur f5 et
cavaliers 5 et 1 mais super g super g
car tous ces quatre noms mais là il va
prendre un truc qui m'a envoyé comme ça
ça au vietnam est d'accord non merci
nous faut pas qu'ils s'amusent avec un
truc aussi attendu en bacs ce même jour
me dire non oui en fait ok d'études
touche ou cabello 86 donc ça c'est un
baume truc à comprendre la position
[Musique]
ouais donc né pour briller souffre mais
pau c'est pas on voit pas ses positions
en profondeur mais c'est déjà plus un 70
pour galfond de yack aux crs chômage
c'est la même position de non il n'a pas
fait de tour d un temps jugé au mieux
mais c'est un danger pour son enfant a
besoin tu t'inquiètes avec son mari qui
est que quatre points
en fait ce qu il va tenter sa chance
il est sérieux quand il joue bien il
joue bien pourquoi pas enfin parmi les
points à chaque fois qu'il a fait en
plus quand il a rien à perdre il est
dangereux mais après je pense que juste
imax il gagne ses deux tours avec bonus
en fait ils mes sauts avec art même je
pense que nancy passe deux tours il
prend trois points il en a 13 soit en a
quatre donc il a neuf points d'avance
neuf points d'avancé sur les clauses
gagne le tournoi avec un point de bonus
déjà si max fait rien si max prend trois
points forts et qui glosent prennent des
points de bonus tout le temps
ouais c'est pas son genre ses patrons
hui non mais ok comme je dis tu as enfin
c'est bien maxi a son destin entre les
mains je pense faut juste gagner donc
donc donc menti du 5e toujours mauvais
pour les membres at a pas trop envie de
le faire tu te fais trop de trous turc
est blanche et il y aura des blocages
quoi le fou à revenir vers 17 caviars
4,5 je sais pas enfin un g5 n'a plus
aucune ambition et tu laisses le joli or
noir donc vaut mieux pas le faire au
niveau du temps on en est où fab dans
cette partie nous dit en attendre des
sur smartphone du coup tu as qui vaut du
temps 1h05 pour max et 40 s'affiche et
42 minutes pour topalov donc les jaf
avance à la pendule
après rien de significatif mais pas
significatif mais carrier qui n'a fait
nulle en fait juste c'était passionnant
mais conserve et krishna
donc ils auront au départage ce sera les
futurs adversaires de iakovenko va
maudire un deuxième tour potentiellement
compliqué pour m'amener toute façon
c'est pas cadeau ni l'un ni l'autre
précariat jeans comme j'ai vraiment pas
un cadeau c'est encore pire donc après
roy g7
iakovenko qui butin publishing non mes
tours 2 1 ça qui peut y penser avec le
caillou 5 et penser si ce machin mais
pressing torje tu vas faire simple le
truc le plus logique moi c'est fou c'est
ce que j'ai montré assez fou prend g63
f4 au moins tu es le roi f4 tu protèges
champions et humains à ce qu'avait lieu
cinq fins et de la rente que dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure qui était avant de
leur dire me paraît perçoit assez
humaine qua non mais le seul problème
c'est que t'as pas tourner oui mais bon
tu prends le cas va les tuer à tout
rachat après enfin je donne quand même
envie de la jouer ça là ouais mais ce
que tu fais plus que ça enfin là nous on
voit avec leur dit que c'est censé pas
le faire mais tu peux avoir envie de
penser que tu fais mieux quand même nom
mais en fait le truc c'est que
clairement il le pain c'est le truc tu
as envie de faire de base
je dis oui ok je domine mais tu
cherchais ce que j'ai pas mieux et eu ça
tue la pousse un peu dans des analyses
pour voir que je gagne ce greenpac pas
raison mais de là à passer après à tours
2-1
tu vois qui donne une grande amplitude
de quoi l'adversaire quand même soir 2-1
en fait c'est quand même chiant ce soit
une menace comprend justice qui est le
seul qui ait pensé si c'est de prendre
des montures et tours 2 1
on ne va pas pouvoir le faire mais je
fais toujours à ses huit puisque ça t'as
vraiment apporté tour d un dans la
position quoi tour assez vite je protège
qu'elle mon fou et ça me servira à
l'avenir palmarès je vois pas trop
l'intérêt en faites pas je comprends
qu'on leur dise doit avoir une idée on
la voit pas mais alors cavaliers g3
jouer dans la partie de maxime
apparemment donc bon ça va te partir la
vente super compliqué et voici max fait
la qualité tout ça c'est nul
apparemment d'après ce que des matières
dans le chat sait que c'est censé être
bien probable mieux depuis trois ans
mais mais ok c'est très que je dirais
bravo possible il va faire non mais ok
c'est juste très risqué parce que tous
les autres qui s'écroule et tu rentres
dans la ligne attendue mais ok s'il a
bien calculé qu'il a confiance et c'est
super ouais mais maxime vachier lagrave
les mecs il va le faire donc on est
resté coi rocklyn chr jmf612 6 ou death
is being torrent
tu as valet h4 qui est proche 4 pour ses
shows crème à jouer ça je serais
tellement jamais rentrer là-dedans fable
mais jamais quoi c'est pas mal c'est en
train de dominer les pièces honneur en
partie décisive comme ça mais c'est ça
le problème éthique j'ai ça dégénère
mais bon après ce que tu as vraiment des
risques est ce que le flou 8e bien
pourri mais non mais où est passé le
rallye corona si je ça passait bien non
mais je dis bravo si le jour mais sanwi
n'en faut j'espère écoutons de son
photographe qui peut jouer d'autres
lignes sur l'instant on n'a pas trop
pris beaucoup de topper en général tout
en votant dafu 17 e et 3 e bay 7 ou des
trucs ils seront d'autres coup jouable
mais en tout cas ça a du sens ces lignes
on a vu depuis tout à l'heure de jouer
qui est si simple qu'elle va revenir
machin c'est assez logique un niveau qui
ça a l'air super bagarre elle joue avec
énormément de buts mais comment et quand
vous gagnez la pulsion avec le sacrifice
bas
tu as le pion passé en une pièce noire
sont dominées tu vas essayer de gratter
un second pion on entend le pion des
vases ou entourage quatre cheveux à quoi
voit la rejettera on va dire tu ouvres
jeu pas où tu veux en fait 5
bon on va faire tourner un k -o 4 on va
gagner qui ont découvert je pense
aujourd'hui notre iphone 4 dont quoi bon
bah taquin atteint un pion pour la
qualité talent pions un passé très
pénible les pièces n'ont eu de tout
coordonner les tours qui seront pas
liées qui rendent pas et d'être vraiment
tu fais g5 qui crée un deuxième pion
passé ou ce cas mais bon après de fer a
dessiné un pénis avec des cinq genres
non mais sûrement faucheux comme sa
dynamique essai de s'activer mais bon ça
s'envoie de bouffer ses pions ouais mais
bon tu peux tu peux arriver un truc
comme ça fait juste montrer que ça peut
se retourner sur le foie arrivants c6
way voitures et motos qu'énergie 6 où je
sais pas si c'est pas gagnant mais tu
peux la gagner que le blanc je préfère
le sac et blanc fait très clairement
qu'elle en fait trop de buts si on
regarde les pièces en fait le foudroie
le khalife 4 il faut un bon tandem tu
prends les cases sur la colonne des ya
pas de tour des deux tours détroit et c
est un truc comme ça tu vas faire jouer
cinq coups des quatre jeux c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche et je leur dis tu
le fais quand même eu oui il va ça c'est
du hockey bomba belles belles lignes
mais je veux dire je suis sûr qu'on peut
être améliorée avant on est peut-être
plus de sa fiancée ça je sais pas enfin
où les pires c'est nul comme ça c'est
une comme ça tu forces lennon est riche
en succès des ordis qu'ils soient
interdits mais mais voilà donc non ce
c'est bien si je serai que moi ces
genres de choses qui peuvent arriver
mais je suis pour pouvoir les tournois
dont tahiti car elles prennent des
couleurs justice tf6 faible alors mais
on va voir je suis pas du tout convaincu
qu'on rentre et je sais pas s'il est ici
c'est en fait sur la filière cette
affaire car il ya quatre ans
très dangereux enfin c'est à deux
violons vacillé après c'est mais avant
tout c'est moi donc j'ai si ce peut être
un jour bien sûr mais pas trop vite quoi
la troupe qui réclament des primes on
s'en remet une petite a boy
du coup pour lui faire plaisir la petite
cuve à mais tu ne vois plus rien dire
pour la pub mais sinon j'ai bien aimé sa
coupe paris c'est beau quand une petite
pub bol oui vous abusez hommes et wat et
simple de toute façon gilles et sa mise
en fiche
ouais non mais je dis ça fait du bien d
petite pub ça donne ça fait permet de
voir d'autres qualités aux gens des
choses des choses bien belle à l'écran
bien cadré qu'à ceux qui a pas de pub
bien joué ça adoucit je plaisantais
marais et non pas de chance et yako et
l'a pris en jeu six mois je n'ai pas bon
tu l'as sur fond de chasse ouais ouais
mais elle a dû prendre mais honnêtement
ce qui paraissait logique un fait de
leur non mais autant oblige tout le
débat n'en veulent pas juste pour ça il
met terreur en faites pas peut-être
qu'il l'a fait qu'il l'a pas fait c'est
le coup de schrödinger quoi on sait pas
why abbas qu'il y ait ça vous tente fait
gagner un abri de chasse comme sur le
disque ordre à coquelles ce qu'est le
lag à partir du quart de finale là on va
faire un concours de pronostics un loto
foot
enfin un loto chaque coin du court par
contre grâce à ses potes s'il ya des
ex-aequo par contre n'a pas calculé avec
best buy orava fait pas un match en
bullet j'en sais rien mais est-ce qu'un
pas quelques avec buzz c'est qu'en fait
si maxime les qualifier dès ce soir en
fait tu fais ressortir à participer quoi
c'est qu'il n'y ait pas pensé mais
c'était tellement tu pense tellement que
les joueurs vont avancer de partout mais
quoique c'est vrai ce que je verrai
vérifier sur fond loach est ce qu'au nom
après toute façon sera tellement content
que maxime soit qualif que j'ai envie de
te dire tant il va offrir des
abonnements à foison claudio ag annonce
a été jours ah non ça a été vous pas
pour ce qu'on en attend c'est parti sur
étant je vais mettre paris frêche c'est
pas si oui non si l'on n'a été joué j'ai
ce point comme ali kushayb non non c'est
n'importe quoi bon se peut très bien que
je suis en partie genton on peut aller
voir ailleurs je les colle à main mais
s'il y en a des blitz à commenter une
affaire
bref du coup il pas mon temps avec 4 il
allait en f2 ça va rentrer dans le jeu
même genre de final que ce qu'on avait
vu way et du côté de maximy a bien eu
qu'à il est 6h geagea pour le moment
mais il n'a pas encore fait vieillissent
de jouer rapidement quais à paris fils
qui peut faire autre chose oui peut
toujours faire autre chose mais écoute
si tu es arrivé de cannes à 9,5 du
concept bien bien ce quiz et un truc
c'est que ces cinq airbus qui a aidé 5
n'a pas envie poker à cavaler h quatre
échecs on a vu après wild duck
lecavalier hk qui faisait pas grand
chose a donc m6 ça reste un peu le seul
coup non mais je sais pas peut-être que
tu fais retour des vies tout je sais pas
quel coup un truc comme ça parce que tu
dis oui qui avec cinq ans jeffrey
caillage qu'acheter changera ce moment
là mais bon peut-être kiev 5 toxiques et
hec regarder mais m6 le problème fatick
si la redoutons pas la fille va regarder
ces localités ça peut effrayer et qu'il
y avait pas de banc ce serait beau oui
il peut que me sacrifier la qualité je
ne vais surtout pas jouer dans mes
saisons ça c'est sûr qu'il va regarder
quoi non mais clairement clairement mais
après c'est peut-être pas si grave
d'après ce qu'on m'a dit peut-être ça
tient si tu rends le pic des 5 bien
comme il faut que tu actives mais ça a
l'air assez dangereux vu de loin ça
m'amuserait pas entrer là d'un canular
mois
te voilà que si je reste him to les
sacrifices de qualité bon je sais gbagbo
sur steam mais il aime bien quoi on est
peut être en train de péter les plombs
il va perdre on va regarder ça mais
pourquoi il le joue à 5 et un court où
je m'écoute
la pression est très difficile pour un
dépôt alors à cinq je peux comprendre tu
veux casser la structure
mais oui il est mal mais c'est fou quand
même autre d'autant craquer quoi bah là
il a fait une partie horrible mais
c'était un très mauvais indicateur est
fière de faire du chant du coq les
blancs ont fait un truc qui est bizarre
là dedans soit il est malade soit il
veut vraiment pas jouer pour une raison
sombre ouais enfin la serre c'est
suicidaire quoi est ce que le grand prix
d'avant en fait il avait fait une énorme
gaffe compte duda il avait perdu bush
père et fils un pion et les jeux ou
quatre ans prises quoi bon ok mais la
partie d'après il a joué cent cinquante
coups bon il a fait nul est donc
éliminée mais il a essayé
enfin c'est pas du tout le même ressenti
que j'ai ici quoi là c'est je fais
nuland ikoula mardi d'après je me trompe
pas prédit coup dans l'ouverture je suis
mal et je me fais défoncer sous quelle
forme il calcule bien normalement
ouais non après ben on va quand même
attendre avant de l'insulter officiel
mais bon goûter des rockets l'aider si
c'est fantastique
l'activité partout bon ça c'est
finalement pour ce avec les blancs mais
ça se voit que tu es bien quoi donc ça
ne tournait pas qui est des coûts ou
créa qu'il fasse très mal mais bon vous
qu'il faut finir le boulot sais pas j'ai
jamais si simple d'ailleurs c'est un des
trucs les plus dures aux échecs
ça se passe bien partout maxime maxi
maxime toujours pas de coût pour le
moment on verra non mais c'est pas
évident on supporte pas flash ans et
mumbai qui dit vous pouvez apprendre à
progresser la sono outil d'entraînement
ya la nouvelle série sorti très
intéressante
il ya 125 vidéos et en français mais dès
janvier qui languit les en garde et je
pense qu'ils ont commencé mais alors que
des retours non parce qu'il faut six
jeunes gens au chat qui ont écrit mais
pas à pas ce pc ranger les gens ils
m'écrivent pas moi il écrira de choses
comme directement mais sinon une chatte
gens avaient l'air d'être très heureux
on est petit on a un petit temps on est
un peu dans le dur la fab beau écoute on
va attendre un peu mais souvent après
deux heures une heure une heure et quart
1h20 deux heures de jeu là c'est un peu
la période est pour bill voss dans le
chat qui demande à près d'un bébé doc y
avait des trois dans la partie de
débauche postulat mise mais mathieu en
train de nager avec un point et cinq
coups rouge
ouais mais c'est dur avoir fait tout ce
qui est des trois tutoie une fourchette
20 suppose qu'il peut mettre ce que j'ai
mis mon ordi du couvre chef d'un bébé
doc et détroit tu te fais fourchette et
donc c'est un peu chiant et donc dame b3
et b4 soit échangé les 5 es tu
t'appelles ça t'a fonds soit 15.7
peut-être même temps qu'elle g5 et prend
2,6
enfin ça leurs violons ok mais donc le
bagel fin d'après midi
5 et là c'est le deuxième client décide
ce qui a l'air très bien mais du coup
c'est moins alors dit moi et de ne pas
plus de poids du coup d'envoi sur sa
chemise et poitrine quand même pour voir
si parce que c'est pas simple en fait de
faire dans le b2b trust pour cette étape
et c'est comme ça enfin c'est ok et
jordi vont devoir tempo parce que eux
ils ont donc une race mais pour un homme
croit après tu fais encore mickael
encore 1 40 ans non mais les écrivains
mais ok si en rouge c'est pas étonnant
il va essayer de faire j 6 3 g7 gigoter
passer sa tour c'est un on nous dit mme
ahmed doit jouer ici roi g7
sinon tour 1 tour 5 assez fort et les
autorités disent mais c'est peut-être au
prochain en fait non mais marine beaury
bien non mais les deux sont mal en fait
enfin je sais pas je pense qu'au moins
l'un des deux va passer à la trappe nous
voir les deux jours aller 2 1 mais
peut-être aujourd'hui un demain quoi
dans ce même chose pour nous assure
absolument rien pardon monsieur il n'y a
pas de fougue 4/4 car il ya 17 ans l'air
topalov tout cas qui réfléchit qui a
presque plus de temps issus non la suite
par soulanges pardon là tous nos
adversaires sûr j'ai envie de te dire
moi des plus hautes qui est bien
toujours là et mes sauts bah si tu as
raison il peut mais bon bah écoute fille
est partie vers que le bonus
donc ils se lancent bien en faites pas
il veut rien faire mieux mais si maxime
prend le bonus aussi voilà avec tous les
tours avec bonus face et quand même dur
mais je s'ajuste aux caisses aura encore
deux ou trois pourcent de chances de
gagner ou un vrai que rhin pourcentage
mais il tire pas mort par contre pour
gris que ce sera fini il sera qualifié
elle a du coup il a remis ses
charentaises il est très heureux non
dissous nightclub à fond mais uniquement
par la critique elle fait quoi katia les
voir commencer plus ou moins non mais
déjà hier la fille quoi bon choix car
signé hier cela rende visite
elle a fait nul hier contre à oxo elle
avait les nerfs et aujourd'hui les
blancs contrarie cas et c'est une roue
libre
c'est important de gagner quoi que
marica à 5 pour lâche 4,4 et demi bon
écoute c'est un autre sujet de notre
tombe et il a fait tourache quatre
cavaliers f 5 mai au caire jeudi donnent
la qualité est en jeu c'est
extraordinaire mais qu'ils foutent vegas
où le taux reste à faire au match 4
non mais c'est pourquoi il doit y avoir
des qualités tout le temps que
d'affirmer didonne la qualité pour
éviter de viol au club innove mais il me
semble qu'elle chante gainsbourg je
rejette ce recours ce qu'il fait mais
qui j'aurais jamais pensé pas juste tu
as tu vois ton h44 a dû bosser mon jeu
font fermer je fais autre chose et ça
rentrer là dedans bah là c'est sûr que
mes web on est très heureux de cette
arme qui a eu 24 calibrage 4 jouer il va
faire rage et 4 max je pense également
que même là elle va gagner va bien sûr
que j'ai 6 et investir.fr g6 de toute
façon ouais ouais c'était solide et tu
vas te faire parce pas sûr que ça gagne
non mais tu viens enfin juste non mais
quand même temps la colonne âge tu peux
rentrer et une colonne des salaires
enfin ok bien sûr c'est solide encore un
peu avec les noirs c'est pas j'ai pas
comment estimer sa ligne en fait
objectivement mais ça me fait marrer
quoi faire du tout par contre ça fait
nul en côte et mam et ça se finit là il
a fait cavalier 4 3 et 7 kg 5 ou key à
nu le côté mamet parties nulles le fap
c'est l'information
ces informations à ce moment la femme
que je te lâches bon bah écoute
pleutre pleutre jeu des pleutres dans le
chat la mettez moi du peu trop de
partout la pleutres mais j'en ai un fan
girl aussi quoi pleutre incroyable
incroyable ya qu est ce qui l'est
sibérien ou est-ce que c'est quoi ça
c'est pleutre de chez pleutre fab
incroyable non mais attendez ça c'est
n'importe quoi
non mais aussi quand on est chic et
s'avère difficile mais c'est le match où
l on peut alors dit mais visuellement
scolaire tellement cool avec les blancs
bâtard néanmoins talent pions basse et
j'ai bientôt de camille fort je me tâte
oursins coms et matthew coiffe un
salaire cool c'est bien vous pouvez
mettre aussi des slips sav peut-être
être un max de slips s dans le chatt
pleutre kouaoua réserver les slips et
ses marins d'eau douce vendus jean
pleutre phare du coup mazona pas là bas
c'est fait soirée avec moi mais comme on
dit plutôt rustre ou slivets trousses
philippe est ok bah du coup on va
attendre l'élimination de nespouls
gentiment et écoute bizou max
mc solaar qu'ont ils à nous convertir
tout ça si jacques on dirait qu'ils sont
énervés dans le chat c'est vous que le
chèque est tombé très bas mais là du
coup on prend plus quoi parce que
normalement les russes manigances tout
il aurait dû assurer la qualif de gris
juke ou a donc qu'est-ce qui se passe on
ne sait pas c'est pas ou alors de
laisser le point de bonus hammam mais on
ne sait pas un peu bizarre
incroyable il ne faut pas voir le mal
partout fab libye
qu'est ce que les gens vont penser quand
ils vont apprendre que leurs droits
compris alors si nippo ajouté ce que bk
ll be rich or die voit pas de mal en
fait que le niveau soit ou non ce
rapport officiel non mais toujours rien
offre officielle d'autres sont ce soir
quoi qu'il arrive là nul ou 3g le 4 juin
donc bon clairement il va nous jouer un
petit j 6 ce qui va il veut bloquer les
cases blanches
le remède le cas l'hiver f5 s'est placé
son fou mais bah du coup max
comment on fait sauter tout ça alors je
pensais peut-être rendre en transport
écolo nash dont kg 6 jouer ah oui c'est
lui maître d'armes arrêt mais bien bien
le maître d'armes en cam la fin j'avais
jamais plus être et flare et dans la
partie de match je comprends pas comment
topi peut avoir du contre eux après j'ai
6 et 5
bah il veut pas le contrôle de bloquer
en fait je veux pas gagner topalov là il
se résigne à essayer de mettre un blocus
en place et c'est tout
et si tu fais c'est 5 etc les blancs
battus fessé 5 l/100 km caliance f5 et
puis voilà c'est une partie qui va durer
1 l'élite bois mais normalement on va
gagner tout de suite pays de galles
indépendant bout
avec les béquilles l'autriche aussi dans
le chat est tous été extraordinaires a
fait plaisir chat vivant mathieu
comprend pas qu'obama et c'est pour ça
qu'on écrit pleutre de partout rend la
charia koffikro à lui dit énervé il ya
eu facebook et hi5 jouer bon ne change
pas la nature faune ne fonde la position
façon après kf5 le foot mais on est en
optimist sur la victoire de max
bondieuseries connaissant topi ça peut
se terminer rapidement
c'est vrai qu'ils peuvent s'envoyer en
l'air total n'en va pas donner une
deuxième qualité donc lui serait beau
qu'il en tout cas veillez matière à spa
je me sacrifie dessus je blâme les cases
blanches comme ça mais c'est pas vrai si
objectivement ses rangs deux gagnants
pour les blancs si un ordi te tiens ça
moi je ferais secours des deux tours h
et en fait c'est très bien ça bon bah en
fait oui c'est parfait je fous 17 quand
même l'air un peu quelque 6 au 10 août a
pas juste qu'un
des bombes à voir si on passait la bombe
a du coup battu le voit quand même non
je sais pas trop quelle est l'idée de
touba on essaiera de voir la suite de la
partie mais vaut toujours youtube on est
bien confiant quoi une si bonne position
ben là depuis dix noms aujourd'hui déjà
non ayant conclu topalov tir qui rate
gagne son match en général voir un petit
récap - terry cap bep coup c'est une
berlinoise
donc voilà et ils ont de la vente qui
tombe donc dans la finale ok 5 bonne
conduite reprend 18 h 3 est très faible
et un plan il faut 17 pour partir skier
vite et avec l'euro alors souri phare de
l'autre côté
les maxima type bien au courant de la
théorie il ajuste ruch f4 bon taf h 6 h
5 monde a vu tomber si si si en
correspondance mais pourquoi pas et ça
l'est c'était pas clair juste là il
prend la mission se rabaisse à tout coup
d'essai
parce qu'ils disent qu'il ya peut-être
et puis là encore bon ça fait les
qualités pour faire un blocage sur cases
blanches et du coup le toit est enfermé
donc la donne ici bon il est prévu une
solution fermés apparemment surpris
quatre points mais toujours est il qu'on
en arrive là alors ça c'est une honte
qu'on imagine et attendait de tout ça
bon allez on a qualifié voilà
mais bon c'est juste une bonne qualité
pour le blanc enfin c'est bien enfin
genre on assez confiant quoi voilà
prendra quand même eu un petit coup de
mou à cause à cause de deuil à duilhac
mais bon ça va
ouais mais ça que je veux dire c'est un
pâton on est juste content s'ils
éliminent mais de bâton
son fiche un peu aussi comme un enfant
qui conviennent aux momies ont misé sur
nous ont bien sûr on va passer tous les
autres perdent en même temps tant mieux
bien sûr on est bien sûr on me surnomme
et si tous les autres perdent c'est
mieux surtout que l'est mam est pas
passé loin de la correctionnelle quand
même tombé complètement complètement
rien compris leur parti enfin
sérieusement joue déjà fait explique un
un niveau de jeu assez famélique n'ont
pas mis au jour est le même le tube
bizarre c'est qu'il ya qu elle plutôt
fait des bons coups faillite et mieux
donc pourquoi fais tu crois que tu
connais j'ai besoin de le dire quand
même un petit peu
il a plu alors dit à un moment quand
même rythme et et bien oui on t'a
devrait être plus de ils exagèrent
l'ordre mais méité juste bien clairement
bien 24 à 0 rice tue près c'était mieux
tu va la gagner c'est souvent quoi des
gens qui ont vu ce que c'était un
complot aussi un attention même
association
d'ailleurs quel autre explication
son truc qui vient du rugby salaires dès
que déclare vitres d'une pénalité ou
quoi complot en plus enfin il y le truc
ça a bien caché leur complot comme ce
que tu vois il le bat il prend pas le
point bonus il veut comploter par les
départage c'est bien masqué c'est pas
mal atalanta soyez 3-0 shakhtar j'ai pas
compris mais en fait ils savent à quoi
si on les trouve dans me2 thème que
possible bien sûr il savait bien ce que
je disais
donc un salut à nicolas élevés sont des
neuf level design je pense 1
il avait dû franchir tous nicolas level
20 jeux les vannes oc nos bottes tenté
de jouer
d'après nautique de l'orge a du coup
c'est bien simple logique tu dire de la
colonne d es tu veux coulisses état de
seconds tours sur la colonne h donc
d'utiliser les deux colonnes ouverte
très bien et empêcher fou 17
voilà donc quoi de plus précieux de plus
logique cook a été un sur proposé sur
sur le stream un coût de qualité tout à
fait tout à fait tout à fait est là en
fait ok d'après les ordi mais je veux
bien croire le seul coup pour garder
truc pas clair c'est ce que celle ci
s'avère en fait j'avais vu sur leur dire
parce que ça fout un peu le bordel s'ils
n'ont fait que je te faire dominer par
tourache un tour âge ça toutefois je
suis libre la rendre partout avec f6 tu
es tu crées d'incertitudes parce que sur
un coup comme tour h1 par exemple que tu
fais preuve en est au moins tu fais
preuve ça tu es ok tu sors acté pièce tu
reviens de 6 tu souffles ouais ouais
mais tu fais pas et sylvain sévit dans
cette étude c'est un peu le sens entre
et on fonce sur paris vii
tu fais pas ça tu es qui veut dominer
parce qu'en fait comme la tour allemand
a change is est un vrai beau faire ces 5
pouces et six barrettes façon qu'ils
font des flops donc tu vas rien faire et
tu écoutes ont bloqué donc en fait c'est
déjà une belle de match entre guillemets
le topless de sauver entre où il fera
partie la faire pour autant jouer car on
est un peu le niveau de mon micro
sélectionné mais j'ai augmenté du fait
que parfois je parle moins fort puisque
je crie souvent en fait je me bats leur
exploser les tympans quoi
mais faute sur le groupe ouais faut
qu'il soit sur le coup du coup j'ai
augmenté mon micro l'ordi 10 / f 6 mai e
5 e et 6 e 6 au 28 novembre soit ce même
sens que d'autres émetteurs comme
l'insee s'est passé mais à qui ce sera
ok c'est pas si non quoi j 5
mais ça c'est logique je vais comme ça
avec les noirs en fait mais ok ça faut
le trouver le g5 en fait faut comprendre
que les cinq épreuves cinq cabanons plus
incompréhensible mais non ma première
vue tu as juste pas envie de faire j'ai
cinq blessés f5 blancois marie
clairement mais bon les mecs font partie
du top niveau mondial on leur donne deux
heures par partie facile c'est pour pas
voir ça il faut tout arrêter un fang
fume sa pendule ne fait pas très beau
temps qui a mal joué tard il a bien fait
il s'applique y fait ce parti on verra
il reste que j'irai parler du reste
quand même 23 minutes encore ça va ça
tranquille
tranquille aujourd'hui ces cas c'est
combien bon c'est pas en fait mais le
problème c'est que le casse-pot actuel
qui appâtent vraiment aux niches qui
depuis quinze ans il touche un peu mais
ils s'en prennent plus j'ai plus rien il
serait peut-être autour de 1700 je sais
pas où 26 quelque chose enfin au moins
26 50 c'est sûr mais ça mais en fait
s'il n'avait pas vraiment raté
l'entraînement je pense qu'ils seraient
encore top 10 demain tu vois un nombre
qui est toujours là jobs a orchestré
pire qu'avant at-il ainsi de la potion
magique lot de jouvence maintenant dos
il est bien entouré par sa femme est
tout aussi important donc puis j'aime
bien jouer et à nandy aussi les nôtres
approche cercla il est punu un mondial
on joue quand même kasparov ont fait dès
qu'il aura pas été no1 mondial il serait
devenu fou
donc il a préféré arrêter tant qu'il
était encore qu'il sentait un peu
peut-être le vent qui allait tourner et
voilà donc je vais être numéro 2 mondial
comment comment puis-je survivre comment
être aussi nul que ça non mais faisait
vraiment c'est sûr c'est sûr qu'ils
pensent et ce à quoi mon niveau de jeu
je n'appartiens pas à ce jeu appartient
pas aux échecs je ne peux plus jouer et
c'est beau quand même ouais donc pour
ces raisons là ils vont ils arrêter donc
en fait maintenant on peut pas savoir
mais je veux dire je suis sûre s'il
avait conclu l'entraînement en quoi il
serait pas vraiment largués mais après
forcément envie sans tu perds tu es un
peu de ta force de calcul toute façon tu
perds ta motive ce qu'on disait déjà
hier etc et il l'aurait pas supporté et
au cas où tu prends la testostérone ça
peut aider ou pas tu penses tu vas
simple l'info ne sera pas lâché et
galfond de cajou et d'amd 5 logica dans
1000 km via le forum et il est très bien
un virus il garde un peu de temps passer
en fait je pense pas qui va gagner
illico presto et fait je pense n'est pas
votre quand même arriver à faire durer
quoi différents à peu près difficilement
mais l'effet de la méfiance à it's not
tu vois
ce qu'à l'époque les smith l'a fait
compagnie n'était pas plus résistants
contre la nouvelle génération
qu'aujourd'hui alors meslot fille l'a
qualifié finale des candidats contre
espoir en 83 ouais et pas toujours à 83
smith la fin j'aurais dit les champions
du monde roncourt 58 donc ses 25 ans
plus tôt elle avait minimum 50 et calque
une cornouaille quand il jouait la
finale 81 compte karpov bien 50 ans a
largement mais le truc c'est que ça a
changé vous sentez de bobigny qui
pensaient que la jeu mature nature aux
échecs c'est 40 ans parce qu'à l'époque
il y avait plus de stratégie que de
calcul du rsa ils été modifiés et en
fait maintenant 40 ans tu penses à ta
retraite ou way back est moins forte à
41 42
car ne crame knicks à peu près pareil
avec cet art vin voilà donc ça change
beaucoup c'est bon on joue pas de la
même manière et deuxième truc en fait la
différence entre les nouvelles et les
anciennes générations c'est que en fait
jouer au même jeu des potes unique ou
bigot reach ou fischer enfin ok vin
partout parce qu'ils ne le signaient
pour mvl nul signé pour mvl fab désolé
deloitte
de te couper là nul a été signée fab ton
explication qui était par ailleurs
intéressante a été coupée formation
pleutre pleutre maxime là on ne peut
rien dire d'autre part m'ont obligé on
peut pas violer sur tout le monde et pas
que je m'attends à ce que je veux dire
au bout d'un moment on doit gueuler sur
nos propres joueurs aussi dire non non
mes fans gays sur tout le monde gueule
sur nous comment l'autre jour j'ai
changé les dates j'avais une pièce de
plus fous je me suis collé pleutres
bonjour j'ai une pièce de flux seul mec
a dû contre le genre zeddam et je suis
plus autrement bah écoutes je sais pas
quel point enfin compliqué à dire après
les bons en clamant le truc c est qu au
départage on est ce qu'on disait favori
maxime mais là je voyais pas en fait
pareil que yakou quoi pourquoi pas jouer
parce qu'on fait voient pas le danger
désormais est ok d'une équipe 6e 6 me
fait existe aussi au bras de fer qui ont
principe mais là tu pars jamais c'est
génial quoi les gens qui disent pleutre
mais on est quand même pour toi et buvez
bah oui mais tu crois pas à la théorie
de dire il est peut-être crevé il veut
s'économiser mais en fait tu t'es con
mais enfin si il va jouer demain
mais s'ils avaient gagné au moins demain
est normal quoi non mais je crois que je
ne sorte cru voir peut-être que c'est
juste qu'il a estimé qu'en fait c'est
une sorte de forteresse parce qu'on voit
là et c'est chaud de passer mais ouais
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'en fait tu
joues comme t'es pas en danger tu peux
donner ce qui est du coup plus souvent
mais si c'est vraiment une forteresse
c'est vraiment une forte hausse ouais
non mais après c'est peut-être le bon
choix de maxime et tout ça c'est juste
sur le coup c'est faire moi aussi mon
m'écrit news regardent nul tu vas chez
apple je suis même choqué j'aimerais
bien qu'on me qu'on fasse un chèque à la
caméra là j'y crois pas trop
l'homme est en fait sur une île avec la
honte food et sa 3e trois fois jusqu'à
trouver soit machin va qu'on verrait ça
je comprends très bien
après peut-être que nous on est
complètement nul et qu'on comprend rien
non mais ça c'est sûr mais le truc c'est
comme on est aussi aidée par l'ordi
mais bon jouer et jouer enfin nathan
laisser-faire rêve si ces jouets 3 4
coups de plus ça me paraissait pas fou
puisque m6 n'était pas sûre à 100%
qu'ils le fassent au pire tu fais nul
après tu ris que rien ne sert que après
tout retour des deux là on a vu tour à
choquer tourache un tour h7 c'est une
vraie menace
c'est vraiment pénible ok on a vu que f6
d'après leur dis ça tenait bien parce
que sur russie saccagé 7 mai au quai au
pire là tu fais e f ou prendre six
cavaliers ou 4 propose nul face à ces
personnes battent la jouer quoi mais
ouais bon du coup je reprends de mon
explication d'avant j'étais lancé dans
un camp gros en fait ce soit stein its
soit capable en cabaude vinik spassky
fischer machin ils ont toujours même jeu
donc tu te sers vais un peu des
trouvailles des autres mais ça progresse
très lentement
maintenant parce qu'avec l'arrivée lors
dit anand à ses débuts et les mecs
maintenant vous aimez c'est pareil pour
qu'elles forment topalov ou quoi c'est
juste deux mondes différents et donc
c'est beaucoup plus dur de lutter contre
des gens qui on leur dit qu'ils se
préparent comme des fous qui te récite
25 coups d'alpha 0 comme ça plutôt que
des mecs qui doit prendre dans des vieux
livres poussiéreux lire bon système bien
machin tu as solidaire et donc cela
explique sans smyth l'oeuf vieux pouvait
lutter contre 1 kasparov quoi petrossian
y luttaient f1 comme kasparov petrossian
a gagné deux premières parties leur
carrière après les perdu les deux autres
mais un score à égalité sur un ensemble
de leur rencontre
donc en fait
bon ok tôt ou tard elle a été un peu
dépassé me l'auraient pas été humiliés
surpasser quoi gp gêne on m'a dit c'est
quoi ça on fait quoi on va sur des
barges et pg nouvelles du pays sinon ils
deviennent numériques ce qui y est fois
la gelée par emailing étoiles je sais
qu'ils ont souffert banon mais
d'habitude moi ça marche ce système là
juste à nos nouveaux sports qui se
basent bas à l'habitude parce sanchez
base ça marche
ben moi j'aime quand je sors je dois ça
marche toujours selon voies normales la
chance
[Musique]
non mais c'est un peu la déception alors
que les mecs c'est un peu le moment de
follow la chaîne là j'ai envie de dire
voilà on fait un peu l'effort on clique
sur follow on suit la chaîne parce qu'on
aime bien les échecs
voilà mais demain ça va être une grosse
journée puisque avec mam et qui fait des
partages d'un côté et maxime de l'autre
ça peut être une journée vraiment très
décisive complètement complètement non
mais après on fait en soi que sept nuls
avant avant la ronde tu m'aurais dit
mais la niaque ruquois est doublement
d'atteindre un sommet on pensait qu'il
est juste perdre en plus merci à petit
fred qui a pris un abo de niveau 1
merci en profiter pour mettre une petite
pub comme ça pendant tu m'envoies le
mail et tous ces faits sont vrais demain
ça va être tout un outil ludique de
large
autant jouer le rapid direct écoute tu
prêches des convaincus il à dire non
mais sérieusement je pense qu'il ya dans
ce genre 30 minutes juste quinze
secondes par coup ou 1h à plus 30 au
parc ou si on veut vraiment faire l'an
j'irai pour ça m'embête parce que le
problème en fait et on se rencontre on
nous commente c'est quand m c'est assez
lent les parties ça monte ça monte mais
hockey était le climax ici oui ça finit
en deux minutes cold climate sam ça me
fait penser à autre chose mais savent
que c'est moins long avant et c'est plus
court mais en gros chez basse qui
construit une narration un film beaucoup
qua non comme ça ou pas c'est comme
ch'ti au tennis tout tie-break ses
premières deux points et tu te bats des
heures tu arrives à 6 6,5 mrd en ce
premier week-end quasiment il a servi
quoi wild carlo vizzini bravo aux
applaudissements quelle tension mais tu
as envie qui dure un peu ce tie break
final kiki et 5,5 6 balles match l'autre
il ya le service il va enlever un os qu
est un moment tu vivre et sa durée
c'est pas juste à bail un point c'est
fini et là en fait je sais pas c'est un
peu ça commençait par thil en dessous
alors quand tu joues tu feras moins
content mais quand tu commentes il ya 8
me qui a fait un grand qu'illégale sur
ty elvis et il a fait un grand coup
illégal surclasse comme ce que vous
attendez regardons ce que tu vois on
épouse
cliquez dessus et papa non il est légal
tongs rock le fouillis contrôle b8
allons à troquer frérot est que si ton
roi est bloquée contre épaule ans non
mais c'est impossible que depuis joué un
coup illégal sur un site
sauf si le truc est mal programmées mais
déjà arrivé mais pas sûr de chasse comme
non non ça va la case et construire mais
c'est la case de la tour par la case du
roi donc tu avais le droit à vladivostok
sourire ta qui étonne même c'est
toujours attaquer cecos il ya un
problème avec le roi que t'as pas loin
donc ça va tu toi aussi tu as pris et
daniel ruch très fort ça peut marcher
avec daniel reyne choix et vous 1-1 chez
le truc illégal quoi c'était passionnant
il est en opposition au kef gagnant
j'aurais pas dit mme avantageuse mais il
a pris là nul pour assurer on est super
contents au bout de deux heures c'est
que là ça va c'est ça un peu le truc c
ailleurs deux heures où tu t'attends
encore un truc et ouais le climax et une
seconde quoi haye a fait nul à pas de
chance
on se revoit demain non mais après en
soit ça va venir je suis assez confiant
pour les rapides tama en termes de
résultats c'est plutôt bien en réalité
ça mal surtout vu que l'eau va peut-être
perdre que que mam et à galérer tout
s'est passé un truc c'est plus dans le
sens où c'est vrai que comment veux tu
que ça devienne populaire et machin six
il faut attendre
enfin oui c'est ce que je suis c'est un
match de tennis de de quatre heures ou
un moment donné en fait les mecs font
nul face à l'orée du quatrième ces
moments on le sait donc jeu bravo très
tu as très bien joué tout le match je ne
jouerai pas ce tie break
non mais en fait qui est nulle moi ça me
dérange pas mais que s'il ya nuit au tie
break parce qu'il ya dix disent quoi
l'armée surtout débattu arrêt tout est
battue j'ai eu dix 10 nuls c'est bon ça
ils te poser ici à face en vainqueur
mais aux échecs le fait qu'il est nul
moi ça me dérange pas mais moi c'est pas
le fait qu'un nul c'est le fait que la
menthe et dure quatre heures à chaque
fois et en même temps on est tous là bah
ouais parce que là c'est quand même un
truc très important pour l'enjeu l'enjeu
et puis voilà plus et on commande paraît
on recommande pas les parties à fond à
fond non plus quoi on parle un peu de
tout de rien d'humanitaire au visage
nous heureusement volt
oui heureusement mais c'est vrai que par
mois ce qui embête c'est que c'est sur
trois jours en fait ça a duré quatre
heures mais tu aurais tout le match en
quatre heures genre les deux
les la qualifie cas-là ça irait mais le
truc c'est que c'est sur trois jours
quoi c'est que tu reviens le lendemain
tu refais toi
il fera jour et direct derrière pourquoi
pas demain c'est 14h alors ouais salut
les gars vous faire un résumé de vous en
et maxime vernon rentrée de mes exams
ben écoute vava sur youtube du coup là
il a fait nul aujourd'hui mais tu peux
aller aller sur youtube et voir la vidéo
en a fait hier parce que du coup on la
refera une tout à l'heure qui se sont
tus pour avoir la partie un peu les
petites subtilités qui peut qu'il y ait
pu avoir ou pas mais on essaie de faire
assez court pour 15 minutes en bas on va
même faire but mais là y'a pas grand
chose à dire on parlera peut-être aussi
de la new wave revenir sur le tableau et
niveau l'op demain 14 heures je ne
pouvais pas suivre merci les gars
c'était cool voir y aura samedi dimanche
taz ont même si enfin si maxime se fait
éliminer mais mam et se qualifie par
exemple on confond continue en fait tant
que nombre d'analystes le temps qu'on
sait pas besoin de frapper ni à quoi il
va jouer après il peut se planter
le problème mais il va pas proposer nul
comme ça quoi là il va essayer de gagner
mais je sais pas qui va gagner cette
réforme
ebeam complètement mais on finir quoi
c'est juste dur de finir c'est toujours
dur aux échecs surtout contre des
athlètes comme un dépôt lundi
il serait contraint naka très confiant
que galfond de la gagne quoi mais mais
contraint et pau c'est plus difficile
c'est plus difficile surtout au niveau
des tableaux en jeu ces choses ont un
peu bougé bah non c'est un peu comme
hier c'est tout le temps
qui aime bien châtie bien quoi
franchement il étape trimer ça alors
franchement ces stries me sens bien bon
c'est parti un peu moi mais il va fait
je vais faire joueur d'échecs juillet
des milliers de bons jeux genre déjà
raide south stream
il vous plaira paix qui doit gagner ou
perdre pour qu'elles me scribe en fait
globalement les autres on s'en fiche si
elle gagne le tournoi il sera qualifié
déjà pour commencer après suivant ce qui
fait au stade ou hyper sa dépendance et
ses adversaires les plus directs c'est
nepomniachi et mamediarov qui serait
plus proche au classement mais c'est pas
complètement s'empare sans les seuls
puisque il y a aussi dit don voelte à
sec
ils sont qui sont bien plus loin mais
c'est pas mathématiquement fait voilà en
gros c'est ça donc en gros si vous êtes
assez avec l unesco éliminés même
éliminé est né peut éliminer
peu importe ce que fera maxime il sera
qualifié après bon savoir que tout
disparaisse d'un coup comme ça donc au
temps au temps comme faire un bon
tournoi
excluant toute mesure que de prier
attendre que les autres perdent
oui et puis prendre des points que les
autres doit enfin doivent aller le plus
loin possible pour se qualifier c'est
ainsi maxime va en finale par exemple je
crois que les autres gagnent le ton à
quoi je crois quelques way m'avait de
gagner tourner je pense même
négociations six bâtiments final ni pau
ne sera pas sur le même moitié de
tableau c'est sa règle d'or meilleur que
moi et plus il va loin plus il augmente
ses chances de se qualifier après là il
prendra pas de point de bonus mais bon
comme mam et n'en prend pas non plus
quelque part j'ai envie de dire c'est
pas sillonnent wolang mini-truque salue
le grand gourou l'arrêt saric s'était
entaillé d'être un moment assez assez
plus double double pleutrerie quoi et on
a vu qu'elles font des propos de nos
jambes et 644 les ordis quoi clip
mais du coup on attend la fin de
parti ou une femme stream georges phone
7 avant 17 heures 17 heures jusqu'à 17
heures regardez un peu d'âme 17 juste
récompense pour demain bien écrire à
samo quoi pour qu'on allait pigé à
d'impression dopants pop art mais il
peut faire quelque chose maintenant la
samah d'où vient le problème
je vais m'en occuper tout de suite
d'ailleurs comment ça va être fait c'est
pas salé qui s'en occupent mais il va il
va défoncer le kaki si on veut te dirait
que quelqu'un se prendre cher wiz
khalifa qui non c'était pas aussi de
pousser pour moi qui bat on pense que si
enfin la vision final fight topalov
trouver fils déjà sinon ça va l'air
d'être galère et même en le trouvant ce
n'est pas fini mais au moins c'était
facile de faire retrouver à six
longueurs maxima finul donc des partages
demain à 14 heures bon on mettra bien
favori un taux pas l'afrique on disait
les parties rapides s'est jamais été son
son point fort mais mais bon ok pour la
fermière quand même essayer déjà sur le
coup sa main ok très bien
c'est génial que sur le coup après une
seconde que tu écris est déjà sur le
coup comme vous je veux mener l enquête
inspecteurs samcon specter sa et mène
déjà l'an iv il force ça demain maxime
va perdre au départage il faudra jamais
les candidats de sa carrière écrit
cransacois non franchement on a déjà
notre très favoris pour les parties
lentes mais là encore plus sont là deux
venant non mais après évidemment on
n'est jamais à l'abri de faire une gaffe
incroyable tu te prends une fourchette
tu perds ta dam mon gamer mais si ça se
passe un peu normalement il vraiment au
dessus
il va se prendre un tour prend 1,5 ouais
ça a piqué un sketch ya un prétoire
prendre 5 comprend la grande attaque la
tourache huit mois plus tard tour vite
dans le viseur donc au détail près 9 5
qui peuvent arriver une marche avec 1 tu
ne vas faire tout ce que tu avais 16
sites on voit non mais franchement je
pense que mon iphone
bien fini sa benne activités des pièces
parlent grand oeuf qu'identique wallach
annonce demain et ben écoute ces 25
minutes plus 2 secondes par coup pendant
deux parties une blanche et noire qui se
qualifie ce sera terminé
si jamais il ya encore un partout que ce
soit 2 nuls ou gains des fêtes
ils auront dix minutes plus 2 secondes
par coup s'il ya un partout ils jouent
en blitz et s'il ya un partout ils
auront l'armageddon
voilà donc il peut y avoir encore cette
partie et ça devait durer ça peut durer
jusqu'à tard ça peut durer jusqu'à tard
ça peut durer juste deux heures de
partir de cinq minutes et basta dur à
dire trois heures je pense un plutôt
parce que je pense à 1h30 entre le début
de chaque partie
2h30 one et diaby n'a tort le grand qui
demandent si ces gagnants tout ça ouais
ça d'argagnon pour les blancs faut juste
finir ce bon là bon si tu sur mes lordi
ou quoi on va finir avec un feu
d'artifice
après sotchi est toujours jamais à
l'abri de tromper mais bon jeune bonne
probabilité pour qu'elle fonde la fhc
inca réalisée sur tours bat déjà très
vite j'ai quatre dames prend 3 g 8 5 et
touriste à son idée ouais bon ce que
ceux ci mais il s'accroche il a trouvé
h5 de l'année il ne joue assez vite si
vous souhaitez y ait des six tours en
effet curieux 4 hier que ses ventes
d'ordis mais dans bonfoh avions sous les
yeux je peux trouver mais non mais c'est
pas fin à cinq pattes leur qui va
simplifier du coup si tu dis est rangée
de ces chiens faut qu'ils trouvent pour
3,5 quoi m'attendre cinq pattes envie de
fermer
tu peux voir rage éviter machin des
nuages 5
bienvenue dans ma fille lily 4g tempo
ouais non mais c'est le bon coup en plus
c'est bien qu'elles font que j'ai treize
contre quatorze minutes bien jeter
catalan ouais ouais non mais c'est ça la
fait il va réfléchir à se mettre en
faillite notent il va sacrifier mais
aucun dépôt oscar lambret comme ça
pourcentage même veine demain dans james
bond je sais pas je te dis quasiment
quasiment 100 pts
bon allez 90 90 riez 25.5 les blancs
sont mal va s'y font pas ton prouver ce
à quoi ils n'en ont fait retour à chaque
course est ils vont s'organiser quoi
normale 5 euros soit faite tant que tu
as ton montrant des six as tu fixes nous
sommes mal commenté mal mais là mais ils
ont une énorme égaliser sais plus mais
hockey lna
ils vont s'en sortir sans plus ça va te
libérer la tourbe et 80 ans du tour à
gstaad
non peut-être quitte à pied tu vas à
lancer un peu des pièces mais il faut
quand même être un peu équilibristes 1
parce que c'est pas agréable j'avais peu
d'espèces comme ça mais voilà prêt ce
serait étonnant que nespouls joue bien
le prochain tour même s'ils se
qualifient gm restructure vraiment mal
et je vois pas se remettre dans le jeu
mais après c'est vrai que six qualifiés
et voyez toujours toujours la brique
mais qu'aucun parti n'a présenté qu'une
épaule il a dit tellement ça en étant un
peu tué trois parties pourries après il
gagne il ya une trois parties de feu s
est vrai que non mais c'est un truc le
coutour d'après ici non c'est pas facile
c'est son château
et solaire il fait quoi bah je peux
ajouter bien sûr manquera pas regarder
ce soir ce que j'y crois un match à
gauche bourgois écoute on s'en fiche un
peu nos géologie seconde il le donne à
aiguilles danaé faire du f4 f5 machin ne
mériterait bien oui mais mais mais avec
ciné pause qualifiés et sautent fait
point de bonus là et point de bonus
derrière c'est que tu as raison en fait
il redevient un adversaire baby-foot
principe
après si maxime passe deux tours c'est
bon mais géré par oui c'est vrai que si
maxime se fait éliminer clotilde a déjà
deux points de bonus et il peut devenir
très dangereux coup bas il va y croire à
sa chance vas y va la tenter par sow
bafin a interdit au dernier je ne veux
pas le candidat est en progrès 5 joue
bien joli quelle forme il va 5 minutes
séparent van bon guelfucci eepad tout
l'autre pour les amicaux puis on va
attendre ajoute sûrement là ça va jouer
vite à mon avis mais bon après c'est
vrai que sow y gagner avec harmonie ci
peut pas travailler il peut être à cinq
points mais on sait jamais faut pas
enterrer quoi après il est loin d'être
seulement il sauve c'est un des mecs on
n'y pense pas trop au kiwi fier mais
julien faut pas enterrer avant ce jeu
par ex il a deux points de bonus il peut
faire dix points maxime en a 13 et c'est
vrai que si maxime marque un point qui
se fait éliminer au tour prochain
victoire dessous avec deux points de
bonus est souillée quoi donc c'est pas
un nom meyers est pas sans un possible
prêt ça demande beaucoup de kim un des
points de bonus qui est notons que
maxime perdu 8 il va faire il faut quoi
mais bon pas si maxime père à ce tour là
où au tour prochain en fait saut en
gagnant aujourd'hui il est dans quoi ce
que je veux dire c'est que ça devient
l'adversaire c'est tout ce que je dis
c'est ok il reste à très peu de
pourcentage mais c'est pas un mec que tu
peut rayer du truc non ça sent surtout
si je veux acheter c'est qu'en 2003
savent que les deux un sursaut avec un
mec en 2003 on aura un des deux qui sera
paix qui sera en finale et qui pourra
éliminer quoi et si elle gagne le toit
il passe devant grille tout coût exact
après sa lourde avec ou sans bonus
teneur est-ce qu'il a sept points de
retard je crois que le temps tourne
assez vite ouais après sa série gothic
monsieur couture bon à prendre
bon on n'est pas fait rage et vite comme
qui comme vous le redis je pense qu'il
va jouer vite mais paula sa série de
savoir s'il va jouer vite et bien en
fait atteint vite va ça fait c'est
sûrement trop tard sigg et le font tous
les bons coups j'invente que tu as
démontré avec le cavalier ya eu 4 à la
fin mai bon d'accord les trouver du coup
il va les trouver
papi girls forme il va les trouver
donc qu'est ce que vous avez dans le
chatt kf5 jeu c'est facile à voir
oui mais vote et cinq sur ce fossile à
metz sait pas qui est ce une fois que tu
y es tu toi fuite pour cet essai plutôt
là qu'il faut trouver qui a aidé 6 tas
de trucs chaque fois que la pression
dans les yeux c'est facile mais vu de
loin est ce que tu dis oui je fais que
les problèmes 5 quand tu anticipes tout
s'est passé comme ça que les haras
reviennent aux échecs c'est pas kemexhe
on ne voit pas un truc en un coup c'est
qu'en fait en amont tu vois une position
qui est loin si tu me diras là où il ya
un terrain compliqué à un moment il
c'est fou mais leur a dit dan 0 0 mais
un bateau qu'est 25 apparemment d'un
même si c'est plus court mais juste déjà
25 c'était plus que temps victoire parce
que tu ouvres la colonne f
tu va me bloquer ali vers l'europe du
bouffin pions pas te fais beaucoup de
choses tmf 6-3 7-6 6-6 majorité non mais
ça c'est quoi celui-ci ferait quoi ceci
sans dépendance et ses atours mais
pourquoi pas tournée
ah [ __ ] tapis on voulait passer ça à
moi je ne sais pas déjà non mais si
c'est pour ça que c'est pas simple de
gagner les échecs c'est dur non mais en
fait c'est un peu dégueulasse parce que
quand tu as tellement dominé tu dois
déjà regagné en fait non pas le mec il
est là il est super mal et il sait
marcher dessus comme ça et puis bon
fanboy toujours les seuls coups de jeu
le coach seul coup mais en fait tu finis
pas ça allait à toby ça pullule annuler
toutes nasa bon pas tout neuf à tout
naze ouais mais c'est vrai que ça pue un
peu quoi enfin ça pue
toutes proportions gardées quoi c'est
quand même serré ce qu'aime qu'elle
fonde qui peut la gagner il n'y a pas de
risque que les peaux la gagne quoi donc
c'est déjà pas mal mais un bouquet
jocistes enflamme tout le mat et sa
fille un truc et puis on a perdu mais là
on va te sais même pas si grave si des
plus de passants je compte sur vous tous
oui mais justement c'est juste que tu
aimerais que sohail que sow va plus
prendre un point bonus kong afin de
combiner paul ensemble à tort à bâbord
20 ghz soit dehors tant mieux aussi
réglé mais c'est pas habitable pas faim
par elsa c'est que c'est serré au lieu
de cagnes n'est pas de champagne parce
que je vois pas du tout galfond
d'éliminer souvent fait non
ça me paraît impossible mais mans après
tu préfères que galfond ni un jour de
repos ça arrive c'est peut-être en fait
plus pour galles flandre bizarrement à
l'entée pour qu'elle fonderait les
genres en plus c était content galfond
d'un jour de repos faire s'ils font
nulle et de delphine se qualifie demain
on l'aura jouant rapide il sera d'autant
plus fatigués pour normes auxquelles il
peut quand même enchaîné trois jours de
suite même là ça fera cinq
normalement on est à fond pour galfond
dans cette partie clairement c'est qu'à
mieux qui gagne dans deux ans c'est
toujours mieux mais il n'y a pas de
savoir le champagne pour autant de
matches et qui avait lieu 4 c'est bien
humain oui mais par des actes la tourte
mais ce qu'ils vont faire date débit
d'imagés
on peut défendre des deux
non mais ça donne ni paire enviée que
les blancs mais juste faut vraiment le
finir kg 5
mais c'est pénible si autant de coups
intéressants oui j'ai envie de tout
regarder la toile vont pousser une
trouve un gain sata bien envie de faire
faire dans le milieu
enfin mais bon t'as une qualité de moins
mais le roi noir est tellement faible
ouais et puis toujours les pièces très
passive ça c'est bien de le pacifier
tour comme ça mais bon ce serait mieux
qu'ils aient qu'un seul coup tu as envie
de regarder genre cavalieri quatre
cavalières 5 lat envie de regarder 2013
six minutes et tu vois non bénéfices j'y
crois pas et après ce gendre qui a eu 4
ou qu'il prenne sa place et ça
donc
regardez pas le chat youtube à la en
fait on a un peu de mal à lui qu'on a
pas mal de problèmes techniques qui se
sont additionnés mais on me regarde de
temps en temps nos jours je n'ai pas
trop regardé n'en est plus au chat
switch un mois baron lâché switch
fenêtres et donc je vois que ça et après
sa totale truc tout le monde mais
j'aimerais si on regarde ça on regarde
plus chic voilà la difficulté
aujourd'hui ce qu'il n'y avait pas les
coûts sur pièces comme de base
on s'est retrouvé à devoir checker les
coûts et regarder les coups sûrs
seulement un moment donné on peut plutôt
regarder plus c'est plus possible les
prophylaxies tiffany pour que l'europe
selon anthony micoud ça je sais pas en
fait il a joué un peu sa partie mais
c'est vrai que la profusion de nuls m'a
l'air de venir au moins un coup trop tôt
a minima qu'à attendre que tout petit
face et si tu prends acte et il propose
le stand mais kalou plus qu il ya des
imprévus tout ce que j'entends je sais
pas voilà ils vont y a qu il s'agissait
pas non plus
aujourd'hui je suis triste pour un nul
pour mv elle il aurait dû la pousser
non après écoute c'est pas faut pas
pousser non plus comme un flipper c'est
ce qui compte c'est en stand by au
départage demain ça va on aime bien
donc ok c'est cool mais clairement il
d'avoir une stratégie de se dire je vais
le prendre en départage suis vraiment
beaucoup plus fort et c'est peut-être
aussi ça le sera et il aurait c'est ce
que carlson fait dans ces finales
champagne mandois 12e partie en fait
quand il allait contre kayak in il a
juste fait nul sans jouer sur la
berlinoise contre caruana elle était
très bien dans la sicilienne la dernière
mais il n'a pas joué j'adore les
commentaires sur de chasse pompe
quoiqu'elle function of time est prédite
drôle mais c'est un excellent chat fait
valoir vraiment que je me fasse un
pseudo pour les jets à fond avec le
sarde est tellement dg dit partout jeu
des trocs mardi le fonds s'est fait
qu'il n'ya carbone monde qui j'imagine
cnvl topalov enfin vu qu'ils ont fini
leur statut rêve de jouer donc en
général tu proposes pas nul tant de
tapage est gris tout cas désormais
officiellement qualifié
bah c'est possible a qualifié ces imams
et gagne le tournoi est il que mv elle
perd en finale un art complet un point
de bonus m.ben ali pu faire que deux
bonus du coup en quarts
plus plus les points des finalistes en
foire et donc ça fait sept points des
mines d'or et 20 mais il est exact
madrid je doute qu'on la première bonne
nouvelle bombe a dû vous pouvez voir
tout le champagne déjà première
bouteille de champagne
ouais pour great chioukh annonce achats
propre nom mais il a fait de très bon
très bon parcours
un poisson il que maxime qui fait de nos
si mon parcours curie même falloir
conclure de si belle manière gagnant car
comment s'appelle en fait ils font un
peu le même truc
pourquoi s'en dire que great choc le
premier grand prix iaaf et finaliste il
est perdu contre les pauvres
le second grand prix il a perdu en demi
groupe maxime gagné mais maxime premier
grand prix il fut finaliste hyper
content de ma maison ont pris part en
demies comme le choc c'est l'allemagne
qui gagne
toranian miroir pas s'ils gagnent
justice oui mais enfin même sens pas
gagné il serait vain de se qualifier
comme est scellé ils font des parcours
similaires pour l'instant pas au même
stade jeunes à maxime avait pris plus de
points de bonus pensant oui ça va
prendre un petit peu mais pas tant plus
en fait même un petit peu de la patte en
plus dans le sang soit écrite ou qu'il a
il a rasé un point de bonus contre
maxime notamment demi après mes
remarques maxime avait pris un point de
bonus en demie contre gries toutes ses
coutures mais non mais maxime pas de
kunming et si tous ces patchs sans les
bonus sans l'air rapides forcément il y
la française a pris beaucoup de points
donc même plus que quelques chocs en
fait mais il reste plus que deux minutes
à à boris gelfand fab waimes force de
cynthia le fait d'avoir pas mal de coups
cc c'est pas de chance jean lydia
s'arrêter mais alors que kf5 et le cas
ce que nous on voit alors dit après on
n'a pas analysé à fond mais on voit
alors dit que les vallées exactement
pareil et c'est juste dommage du coup de
se voir perdre du temps pour pour
choisir ce que les deux soient rock néo
qui ait aucun gagnant force donc en fait
tu peux réfléchir réfléchir il n'ya rien
quoi qui donne autant des commerces
liaison de tp finale au tennis ou
presque
mais dans l'esprit si ça arrive il est
parti à cayeux 4 en fait juste avancé
cli candidats le vainqueur va à la fin
je le championnat du monde comme le
champion du monde en titre dont c'est
comme si au tennis le numéro un mondial
ne jouez pas le masters il était déjà
qualifiée pour autre chose on va dire en
gros seins et que le master sarret de
grosse explication finale de fin de
saison et le vainqueur du masters va
jouer contre 1 mondial mon combat d'al
jawf 1
là ça serait ça été un match on serait
pas que ce serait pas qu'un match de
tennis stage arts / sur six matchs sur
différentes surfaces peut-être qu un
truc comme ça mais ça se ressemble
s'assemble ça ok qu'est le 4 juin sur
huit
alors soit comme des huîtres ou
d'affaires touré suite et que la clape 6
m'étais mal quoi mais moi je sature
comme si je finis mais a pu bien parce
que tu as vraiment un endroit pour y et
puis les pions parce équipe enfin ces
six baies sata par garnements quoi donc
sa voix non madame des 8 tu t'accroches
monté mâles dans tous les cas le savoir
quelle souffrance tu as tu veux leur
proposer calcul proposé à dar es 6 qui
était à moi mais un trop plein d'eau
mais si c'est après tout rush promise à
nice je reviens juste et mg l a proposé
nu wade a proposé nul qui a été acceptée
par topaloff
bon on va voir comment ça continue ici
donc le cas payet emprise me rappelle
que bien sûr la tour des huit aussi donc
on n'a pas trop envie avec les noirs de
perdre la qualité comme ça et du coup et
que les blancs de la société à l éthique
fourche à trois dames pour ça qu'on
suggère d'amd 8 qui au moins défend la
tour et enlève la dame de la fourchette
cela dit on est loin d'être sorti
d'affairé nord puisqu'il ya cavaliers g5
qui peut arriver à cette position
toujours pareil ne peut pas prendre un
cavalier parce que il ya tant d hitler
donc voila et le cake fringer cinq
sacres et désastres du roi tu voudrais
que les flèches 2 me 6 à 9 7 notamment
donc je vous reviens stabiliser les
cavaliers et noir qui sont assez chiante
son tour des huit ou neuf ans que là
pour virer la dame doit se rendre du
cabillaud 6 mhz nous sommes contre
ouais le tour des satcheux pas quel
monde mais j'en retiens aussi ce qui est
premier dividende en trombe et sather
après il peut essayer de marivent à
tâtons d'un très bon vas tu as juste y
ont passé objectivement perdants après
c'est sûr qu'avec une ode à la pendule
du stade épi cheapos par ci par là
jamais l'avouer je pense qu'il ya
vraiment intérêt à jouer vite hein faut
pas laisser trop de temps là non mais
enrichie pour enchaîner les coups à fond
ces perdants pour n'est pas prêt francs
4 d'en prendre huit mains pas vraiment
perdant mais s'appuie bien cette annonce
a pu complètement mais bon c'est pas
abandon coiffer encore le finir mais ça
devient de pire en pire
exactement non je pense vraiment que je
vois vraiment et poté comme déjà il a
fait tout réfute donc bouclée puisque
est joué il va claquer la qualité dessus
un peu obligé il va tenter roche
[Musique]
satellite toowaytm et il va jouer pour
un père pète ou un truc quoi non mais ça
pue ça pue mais c'est pas 100% gagner
pour les blancs s'est pas encore une
position où tu dis c'est gagner quoi non
c'est pas du 100 % n'ont pas le monde
plus sûr mais voilà on est plutôt pour
défendre dans l'intérêt de maxime mais
bon c'est pas vital quoi loin de là bas
juste en fait comme maxime a fini bon
continue de suivre puis pas cette partie
si nul que ça nous intéresse le plus
voilà simplement vu la situation dans le
tournoi et l'intérêt du tournoi bref
c'est sur 100 % à mon avis
quoi d'autre non là y'a pas d'autres
coups et on va voir après si elle commet
galfond de continue on his vivent une
épaule pourquoi vivre des peaux hâlées
bourhis ya intérieur pour rapports de
tous les côtés ni gauche au sax eu un
peu maintenant de bien gala au monde
peut être un peu chaud je ne suis pas de
mode ou enfin fait pareil c'est un
adversaire plus facile au deuxième tour
en cas de qualification je pense en
liquide mais bon ouais mais bon oui
peu importe ton courage c'est de jouer
et quelle forme qui a que deux minutes
et non mais c'est pas du 100 % pur régal
fendre c'est pas du 100 %
c'est vrai que quand je suis né dans le
shaq le roi est un peu faible et il peut
y avoir des idées de perpète des choses
la branche le seul coup d'après leur dit
qu'ils gardent un bel avantage cc6 en
premier puis on prend et tourer mais bon
après c'est très logique puisque on veut
tous recettes et surtout rue huit tours
prend 1,8 dame prend 8 du coup on a le
pion b passé vous les montre encore dit
et les paires plateau enfin bien faire
preuve deux sur un mille pour cent de
votes parce qu'on ne gagne vraiment ça
non mais ce qui est pénible c'est que
nepos et une calculatrice c'est un peu
un mvl écueil c'est fait il va te jouer
tempo en fait c'est sûr ce sera blessé à
l'éclair et galfond il a une minute et
il lui reste encore six coups à faire
etc je pensais les faits en fait super
c6 bc nanani nanana roi f2i temps reste
encore trois autres dom de cet homme
pauvre
oui c'est sûr come back là je pense
qu'il fait plutôt dan 17 pour pas se
prendre des chèques 1 pour votre fausses
données se fait chier ça mais bon ça se
trouve ça a mûri comme ça tu t'es mal
placé puis ça revient pas
enfin en tout cas il va te calcule et le
truc qui est le mieux parce qu'il est
fort non il te le redis f4 n'ai-je pas
pourquoi la f4 y penser aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il va te trouver enfin il va
diva toujours un coup pénible pratiques
et valérie la fée tour raté méthode
indirecte
non mais c'est dur de faire ceci c'est
vrai je sais pas je comprends donc il
n'a pas fait c'est si cela fait tout un
direct plus en plus coûteux nul en fait
toujours huit tours prend 1,8 d'un prend
1,8
ben non l'ordi donne 0 0 bon ok c'est
pas beaucoup d'emplois nulles
non mais géré par la queue on passe
d'une position il est plus plus 150 puis
160 très dur à jouer pour les noirs et
maintenant je dirais c'est plus dur à
jouer pour fins pas plusieurs jours les
blancs dans le sens où la pollution est
toujours meilleure mais c'est plus
difficile de trouver les coûts précis
pour mettre les noirs en difficulté
n'est qu une époque il reste un rêve
écoute c'est le scénario vraiment
investir et ils ont fait nul signe est
incroyable et votre un peu varié pour
voir vous donc il s'en fout il a ici un
g jusque il a pas trop lui avaient cessé
en ayant verdière série hier c'est
maxime en difficulté les deux autres
bien voir un des deux autres un des deux
autres biens mais finalement maxime qui
s'en sort et mam et firat
oui c'est l'inversé maxime bien les deux
autres dans le dur et tu dis bon on va
vous en sortir a aujourd'hui et
s'écouler en fait maxime qui passe pas
avec le bonus et les deux autres qui
sauf moi je pensais qu'il veut au moins
et phuket ou mam et 20 des deux fusées
au mal quoi et en plus l'autre mauvaise
nouvelle on peut peut-être rester une
seconde juste sur le design de 2
deux sauts je le mets en grand écran
peut pas bouger les pièces mais voilà
juste pour terminer pour terminer là
dessus n'hésitez pas à flots la chaîne
souhaite là pour la première fois de
toute façon nous on sera de retour avec
fabas dès demain à 14 heures pour les
départager en plus à être dépôt des
partages puisqu'il va avoir beaucoup de
joueurs
oui qu'on va suivre donc on suivra un
peu un peu un peu de partout ce sera
vraiment sympa et donc juste la voir ont
fini jusqu'à 17 heures quand on fait les
cinq dernières minutes sur sur junghee
mes apps qui un sac fils de qualité
d'âme c2a cudi l'ordi comme un bonze pas
encore vu non plus l oms une bonne
d'autres ça va être chaud à vii jouer
mais alors voyez fuite ça sans forcer
comme beaucoup de temps sous la terre du
fou des singles l'armée donc sow se
place vraiment quoi en gagnant comme sa
fin il se place vraiment il reste
intéressant court soit il est peut être
trop lourd pour qu'il la game watch de
cette cour où ge
je pensais courage ben ouais ou la wii
c'est fini bah faut encore finir que
j'ai alors dit à mes cinq dames j'ai ici
ben moi je ferai juste donne des 6 mdsy
soit en fait oui d'anne decis fait roi
fx était logique ce que ça empêcher adam
des six trois premiers sets mais assure
d'année si c'est quoi le bail 1 0 et
chute le problème je pense c'était qu'il
avait vu dam des six échecs rois princes
est d'amener cet échec et bouffe j'ai
sauté qui s'est dit ok pas l'automne
mais la prime de donne des 6es que
l'année six dames 4 ouais mais bon tu
bouges ton fou a pas de feu dame quoi
notre force et 5 par exemple
oui il faut s'inquiéter reid a mené 6-4
ouais donc saut ce qui se passe vraiment
très loin fasse aimer tout cas elle peut
pas rêver mieux il joue son match il le
gagne avec bonus prend le bonus contre
lyon guy tu vois c'est pas ça veut dire
qu'il est bien on pouvait dire que la
fin de cette journée bon basso
fini tu vois on compte pas survivre ont
du coup là il te dis ok si maxime se
fait éliminé avant les demies je suis là
je peux tu vois tu là et il te dit que
s'il ya un deuxième tournée posso en
fait si maxime père dans tous les cas tu
as un mec hyper relou qui va pas c'est
quoi donc un petit mais quand même une
pression dames 5 et appelé le jeu le
plus précis ensuite comme g6 il vient de
sat
ils te poussent le pion de bouloc mais
je pense avoir les hautes sphères dame
justice quand même youpiii merci
mutation dams est tu n'en fais plus huit
mois alors attendre quitté toulon et
dire au revoir
petite pub a quand même à prendre comme
ça mais à bella bella belle journée
fabre braques ou tu sais pas si mal
bouffe on ya cru un peu moins vous
pouvez tenter le bonus c'est vrai quand
tu entends pas le bonus fab il s y
l'assaut à portée de fusil entre
guillemets bah oui non peut te chie maxi
il passe ses deux premiers tours face on
s'offre à ce qu'il veut ce radar enders
deux belles journées sans regard de mv
louis mais aujourd'hui ça a été
paris s'est passé quand même des petits
trucs favori hui d un frémissement
non il est vrai qu'ils sont enfin il ya
eu mais gérer non mais il est nul il
s'est passé des familles s'étaient pas
des nuls insipides dans toutes les
parties à penser que quelqu'un pouvait
gagner et justice ont proposé nul
y'a que gagne pour le moment on pouvait
s'y attendre leur vol
et qu'est ce que j'ai en avril pour se
faire suer à bon dieu au cinéma prayssas
et pas non non vous vous voilà que fait
bongo candidat du coup quoi il sue
non mais ça me fait plaisir pour ça en
fait savoir que j'aime bien du coup
ouais on aime bien ou pas non mais alors
à nous piquer la place non plus
franchement je suis maître du suspense
je m'inquiète pas mais c'est passé à
remettre un gars sympa non mais oui
voyons dans son petit monde comme hey ya
j'ai entendu de mal sur lui une faute
ouais ouais donc non mais juste soit à
des joueurs avec les pour lesquels toi
tu as envie d'avoir une sympathie quoi
je sais pas discret sympa est-ce qu'elle
va les assurés de faire les candidats
non non pas encore non mais comics dc de
23 décembre on pourra te répond
peut-être même hauteur
enfin il est quand même américain wemmel
et philip parham et avec un an mais je
ne sais pas c'est un aveu il serait bien
qu'un ce que le problème mais c'est un
gars qui a l'air kalla qui a l'air cool
après voilà on espère qu'ils se fassent
éliminer un peu avant mais je suis
content qu'ils reprennent un peu ça car
en bas rhin qui bat tous junghee tu vois
qui nous gagne un petit peu quelque
chose un peu quelque chose ça un bien
changé l'époque du sto bashing ce qui
joue aussi insipide que karine baillet
quand même champion du monde de 960 en
speech est si nous a fait plaisir
bron et plus largement je pars il est
sympa non mais après c'est sûr que son
général c'est pas le mec qui va te faire
le beau jeu à fond quoi mais en fait
après entre da manière dont tu joues ta
personnalité le fait soit c'est un beau
gosse avait quand même deux choses
différentes
peu mal joué aux échecs est très sympa
ou très bien joué entre être un conte
aussi fait un jeu dire on peut bien aimé
peut-être le mec s'il est sympa ou pas
peu importe
non mais je trouve que son son match en
960 contre carl scène tu vois ça pour
moi ça lui a fait reprendre sur un
certain capital sympathie bas en plus
ouais mais il montre qu'il veut jouer je
vais pas mais moi oui oui puis bon 960
entre guillemets c'est vrai échec est
bon qu'ils te défonce le champion du
monde 13 heures comme un toit sans
ouverture il te montre qu'il est très
fort donc ça c'est un peu casse aussi
l'image du sceau tu vois bien préparés
nanani nanana
c'est signé il peut y est très bien
réparé quoi mais je crois qu'il est fort
en plus et que globalement ce sont tous
les joueurs qu'on regarde et c'est vrai
que ça casse un peu quelque part pour le
public de voir toujours les prépas les
variantes machin mais ça n'empêche pas
que ça se calme les meilleurs joueurs
d'échecs tout court oui oui et puis là
tu vois alors la position ils vont quand
même très bon coup dans une compétition
il ya quasiment que des nues baala le
premier à prendre un point complet ses
sauts finalement donc voilà sans paille
il évoluer vos l'arbre mais il ya
meilleur espoir du mont les amis
c'est le plus fort wesley pour un saut
je la gagne et les amis qui jouent la
qualif aux candidats les amis marseille
joue le titre
bon du coup il est temps de se quitter
merci à tous ceux qui ont sué ce stream
on va vous préparé le petit résumé avec
frappe de la partie pour que vous
puissiez l'avoir enfin c'est surtout
pour ceux du cou qui n'ont pas pu voir
le live depuis le début et puis on se
retrouve demain à partir de 14h pour
dédé partage de feu n'hésitez pas à
follow la chaîne parce que du coup vous
aurez les petites motifs quand sa part
live de sable pour ceux qui veulent plus
avoir les pubs de dire au revoir à fable
parce qu'il est toujours beau est
toujours là et on se retrouve demain
aller